on envoie le petit raid
je vais je remets l'échiquets bien on va
récupérer partie je vais récupérer
joueurs et je vais récupérer Baki d'une
Irx ou y j'ai complètement oublié qu'il
faisait le les parties les parties sur
zoom donc qui est très très mal mais on
va le récupérer ne vous inquiétez pas
une petite seconde j'espère que le raid
a fonctionné
de toute façon l'avantage du speech
l'énorme avantage avec le speechess
c'est qu'on a le temps
parce que c'est long
non j'ai d'abord récup les joueurs et
après je vais réussir à récupérer
il y a aucun problème
on se retrouve avec des choses qu'on
devrait pas avoir à l'écran
on va récupérer du mvl ambulant
donc attendez je vais récupérer
c'est pas c'est pas ça du tout
c'est pas ça du tout
on va récupérer joueurs et après on va
s'occuper de récupérer
attendez au moins on va on va on va
mettre les choses comme il faut
ça c'est Maxime
n'est pas ça va arriver aussi
j'ai complètement oublié qu'ils
utilisaient zoom aussi pour et qu'on
pouvait pas utiliser deux zoom c'est
vraiment pas pratique
on peut pas ouvrir deux conférences zoom
en même temps
sans risquer de bug en tout cas
de façon le match a pas encore comment
c'est on a on a le temps
OK
le nom des joueurs on va les changer
ok donc déjà ça c'est bon on va mettre
la partie
ok bon ça c'est pas lancé et c'était pas
lancé attendez on va on va je vais
écrire un Baki qu'on va essayer de le
récupérer
on a les joueurs on a on a tout on déjà
là on est pas mal il nous manque il nous
manque plus que il nous manque plus de
batterie
qu'on va récupérer
qu'on va récupérer facilement
la partie c'est qui c'est non c'est dans
l'autre sens
hop c'est néo avec les Blancs et CMV
avec les noirs
il manque l'essentiel bah ouais il
manque Baki pour le moment
mais oui en plus du coup ça a décalé le
design
il est pendules sont inversés non c'est
bon c'est bon c'est bon là là c'est
parfait
il y a tout qui est censé marcher
comme il faut et Maxime qui a une
position correcte pour le moment il
envoie un punto il veut se venger sur 4
donc il a pas perdu de pions là Maxime
et à la pendule noire qui est un tout
petit peu plus petite
que la blanche
sans qu'on sache trop pourquoi
en tout cas là il a une position
correcte c'est échange ici on va Maxime
qui s'alimente
il prend des six prend des 6 faut pas
enlever le blanc ouais il faut enlever
le blanc noir
c'est leur design qui est pas en fait
leur design il est pas fait pour suivre
qu'un joueur il est fait pour changer
entre chaque partie sauf que nous enfin
je pense qu'on suit tout le match du
côté de Maxime là on est d'accord
là-dessus
je vois pas pourquoi on
je vois pas pourquoi on changerait de
joueur en fait
on s'en fiche complètement
donc cavalier prendre et là Maxime qui a
un pion de moins mais qui va récupérer B
donc ça ça va faire nul qui P3 mais ah à
tourbé 3 il y a encore qui va tourner
mais oui qui est béca c'est bien joué ça
va prendre prendre H3 vous prend B2 et
ça va tout échanger ça va faire nul dans
la première
ça va faire nul dans la première partie
pas de problème pour pour Maxime
nul facile au noir ouais nul tranquille
là je vois pas comment les pots peut
protéger son pion il peut peut-être
tenter fou F4 quand même pour gagner un
temps
bon il fait cavalier c'est 5 Maxime qui
doit calculer cavalier à deux ici
j'imagine
parce que ça touche le fou est-ce qu'il
y a une idée surtout à des fait tourbé 5
en gros ce pion il y a pas de scénario
normalement où il reste en vie mais
évidemment il faut être vigilant qui a
été trois
touches le Punto et là ça va
terminer le problème qui va faire gaffe
en fait il faut F3 encore un truc et
b2b1 mais normalement même un tour des
cinq à ce moment-là marcherait ouais
bien joué tourner il voulait cavaliers
B2 tours D8 peut-être il faut H6 et là
pardon j'ai cinq c'est moi qui ai mis ce
clic
et là il veut [ __ ] en B2 tourbé un
donc pour B4 de Maxime qui harcèle le
cavalier tour à 8 et incroyable il a
gardé le Punto en vie n'est pas
quel artiste qu'est-ce que c'est bien
joué
bon le truc c'est qu'il y a encore fou
cette fois F6 vous prend B2 qui arrive
et qui a l'air assez inéluctable mais
quelle défense incroyable n'est pas
bon là de toute façon l'option est
bloqué il peut pas avancer il y a pas de
souci mais il veut encore fou F6
cavalier c'est 5 tours cavalier aussi 3G
8 tours à huit maths
mais qu'est-ce que ça joue bien mesdames
et messieurs mais peut-être qu'on peut
faire [ __ ] en B2
cavalier E63 F6
cavalier F4 encore pour menacer cahier
des 5 bon ça commence sur les chapeaux
de roue
Maxime qui joue à G8
il n'y a pas fous des quatre fous des
quatre qui a valu aussi ce qui est prend
des sites cavaliers prend des quatre
attention
et là peut-être cavalier D3 alors dis
donc 3 tourbé 8 tours à deux et avantage
blanc mais quelle partie qui est en
train de faire n'est pas
c'est impressionnant il va réussir à
faire B4 et à mettre pression mesdames
et messieurs
ce que Diane n'est pas bien chier vient
de faire sur cette séquence de coût et
absolument incroyable
ouais c'est absolument incroyable
mesdames et messieurs
ouais c'est du jamais vu c'est du jamais
vu enfin j'étais convaincu que que
Maxime gagner espion facilement alors
c'est toujours nul mais Yann qui a
réussi à mettre pression
il a réussi à créer quelque chose avec
rien
c'est très très solide
ouais maintenant il va commencer à
avancer un B53 F3 roi C4 le cavalier des
trois qui tient tout ouais c'est une
mauvaise augure cette première game ciné
pour réussir à la gagner
parce que réussir après c'est ça c'est
absolument incroyable
on va récupérer Baki au passage mais là
dans des cinq on va le récupérer sur
discord
on va récupérer Baki sur discord on va
on a réussi à mettre Baki sur discord
c'est terrible mais là cette partie
elle se passe très mal
ouais c'est dur c'est dur ça avance
pour ces deux
à Maxime qui a peut-être réussi à
trouver à trouver du contre ici
B6 tu reprends F2 B7 on va suivre la
partie jusqu'au bout on s'occupera du
discord de Bachy après parce que là il y
a des choses qui se passent pour un F2
b78 d'après l'ordi tiens encore
mais bon ça fait très peur il y a du
cavalier à 5 cavaliers c'est 6 qui
traînent derrière plus de 22 secondes
pour Maxime
bien joué peut-être poussé 7 cavalier C5
tours D2 échecs
il y aura peut-être du roi C6 après
cavaliers des 7 est-ce que le fou peut
garder une cage sur la diagonale
alors dis donne nul ici grâce à 4 F4
peut-être marche aussi si on prend fou
prends HK G5 Maxime qui va obtenir
peut-être son contre jeu peut-être du
cavalier aussi à ce moment-là qui
touchera le fou et le pion
mais il aura peut-être le temps de cette
maxime qui va peut-être la sauver mais
quelle partie de fou
plutôt avec H3 ah oui j'ai 5 à cavaliers
aussi quand même
parce que le Fou est bloqué à la défense
de B8 fois H2 Roissy
sur cavalier à 6 il y a roi du 8
B8 dames il prend G4 H4 G3 et le
cavalier a pas le temps de revenir
apparemment
donc ces cavaliers à 6 3D 8 3D 5 le coup
peut-être
H4 G4 H4 il y a pas de G3 parce qu'il y
a dame
oh il va y avoir roi E4 B8 dames le
cavalier va revenir et c'est gagnant
pour ne pas
quel début de match de Yann
ça c'est une Master Class alors attendez
on va récupérer maintenant
je vais l'ajouter
en ami
et on va réussir à le récupérer très
rapidement
on va le réussir à la récupérer très
et on va voir c'est commentaire
allez hop on va l'appeler et ça devrait
marcher
on va déjà avoir le vocal
est-ce que tu m'entends bienvenue sur
ton premier salon vocal ça fait plaisir
ça fait plaisir ça fait plaisir je vais
te partager des chéquiers si tu peux
mettre ta cam on est parfait au moins tu
vois tout c'est mon premier j'ai jamais
à cet emprunt tu as vu la partie
incroyable Yann c'est fini je suis
incroyable
il est fort ça va être très très dur ce
soir pour Maxime
Yann qui en grande forme le finish a été
assez impressionnant mais toute la
séquence là où il a gardé le pion en vie
c'était assez incroyable j'ai loupé tout
ça parce que j'étais en train de j'ai
mis 11 minutes quand même à te connaître
c'était l'imprévu dernière minute est
complètement zappé cette fin de cheescom
tellement bizarre d'utiliser le zoom
pour pour faire ça en plus mais bon
OK
bien tu vois bien tu vois bien l'écran
tu vois tout
on a du
[Musique]
il a joué la berlinoise
est-ce que tu as réussi à mettre ta cam
oui attends tu me vois pas alors attends
c'est bon je te vois je te vois bah qui
tu m'entends toujours
attendez j'entends plus bas qui j'ai eu
un bug oh c'est terrible c'est terrible
on a pas de bol là on se début
on a des petits problèmes techniques tu
vois tu vois l'écran tu vois tout c'est
bon c'est bon
et au moins on va être on va être
complètement tranquille alors attends
comment on est complètement tranquille
je vais rajouter ta câble il faut que je
me connecte à la chaise comme et
regarder la partie de Maxime alors
exactement
ce sera le plus simple ça marche
OK
c'est exactement ça
habituel on est on est on est très loin
du setup habituel les amis et je vais
laisser backy vous expliquer la partie
pendant que je récupère le temps le
temps que je me mette vas-y mets-toi à
du coup on a quoi une position assez
symétrique pour le moment on voit le
foot B7 quand même qui est moins bien en
place que le que le fou
en G2 qui a qui tape sur sur le Punto
qui tape sur le Punto D5
alors que le fou des 7 lui est en
réaction entre guillemets que tape
contre le mur le fouet 4 légèrement
lui aussi
mieux placé que le foie F6 puisqu'il
tape sur quelque chose de faible alors
que le foie F6 tape tape sur du dur donc
ça ce sont les deux avantages de Maxime
et un petit avantage de développement
aussi sur la colonne E mais une fois
qu'on a dit tout ça c'est pas non plus
énorme parce que si les Noirs
réussissent à faire genre c'est 6 tours
8 tout échangé le long de la colonne e
ben l'avantage il va s'estomper et les
Noirs vont réussir à égaliser donc
Maxime qui a décidé d'échanger les fous
donc l'idée de cet échange de fou c'est
de gagner du temps de développement pour
essayer de taper sur le pion des 5 et
peut-être jouer une finale avec bon fou
contre mauvais foi à la fin donc il y a
il y a deux trois petites idées ça et là
maintenant on va voir si ça fonctionne
ou pas il a des toqué comme tu as
expliqué c'est des tout petits avantages
positionnels
c'est très très léger
ouais mais bon ils existent mieux vaut
avoir des petits plus que pas
ils sont présents on est d'accord c'est
toujours agréable de jouer ça en
blitz ou en rapide de jouer de jouer ces
berlinoises avec toi
si tu les as pendant tout le match c'est
très très cool
donc il utilise un désavant un avantage
c'est le foot casse blanche il en reste
plus qu'un mais bon c'est pratique
après c'est 6 il va peut-être prendre
une fois et en cas d'échange dans le 5
il aura des preuves 5 contre il jouera
contre un pion une structure légèrement
avantageuse mais il y a peu de pièces
quand même
mouais mais bon c'est bien pour rentrer
dans le match quand même de jouer une
bonne position après le bouillon enfin
pas le bouillon qui s'est pris dans la
première mais après la grosse partie de
Yann c'est bien d'avoir une partie où tu
es où tu es mieux quoi
c'est le genre de position que Yann
n'aime pas trop en plus normalement
normalement il n'aime pas trop
là il prend le pion quand même
moi ça a l'air mieux ça a l'air
clairement mieux pour Maxime dame trois
Tour Eiffel c'est vrai avantage non
il va faire peut-être un rashka après un
A3 après un dame E3 tours
c'est pas le genre de position qu'il y a
fait un B4 mais sur Dame des 6 là tu
comprends pas pourquoi il est rentré
là-dedans
parce que damaka
faut vraiment qu'il aille Maxime Sala
répondent tout de suite à Yann pour pas
le laisser rentrer dans son match
donc tu remontre
j'imagine que demain tu reprends le 5
dans 35 c'est pas vraiment suffisant
donc là il doit jouer d'un pétrole dame
C4
ou revenir en D2 il vient de D2
[Musique]
position il prend son temps au bon
moment ok dame B3
bizarre cet échange de cool j'ai du mal
à comprendre
cette recette ça a l'air très bien ici
non qu'il y avait une
salaire avantage gros avantage blanc non
ouais parce qu'en plus tout recettes si
Dame C8 il y a pas de D6
tu reprends des 6 faut prendre B7 d'un
prends baisser de dame prends des six
ça doit hein
des cinq
ouais elle était peut-être pas
complètement gagnante et il
rejoints
comme ça dans un match comme ça contre
Maxime pour en vue de son match
championnat du monde
une erreur là quelque part il a juste
redonné le pion Maxime il y a une faute
c'était peut-être le D6 non qui est pas
qui est pas passé
bah
c'est nul ok c'est dommage que Maxime il
laisse passer
deux demi point en fait là sur les deux
une fois de tactique qui est encore on
est là demi point on est gentil c'est
déjà Yann qui qui va pousser maintenant
ça peut être le genre de position qui
est pas ok bien sûr c'est nul mais c'est
plutôt les blancs qui doivent être
précis genre là s'il fait roi de 6-3d7
il aura peut-être des dames C6 tu as
raison c'est en plus
il y a une minute trente d'avance pour
pour Yann très dur à jouer et très dur à
défendre le roi voilà
très bien joué de la part de Yann début
de match compliqué
il a fait des il a fait des coups un peu
bizarres au début mais là là il est
impérial dans la phase technique
et une minute 39
de la part de Maxime
pour le roi même s'il y a des échanges
ta B3 qui est très faible
c'est en pratique c'est intenable ce
genre de position
qui joue deux trois coups vite
il a bien joué Maxime là les deux trois
derniers
il va falloir jouer 25 coups comme ça
c'est ça le problème impossible n'est
pas Maxime Baki mais oui là tu as raison
ici c'est vrai bah tu as complètement
pressenti ce qui allait se passer plus
qu'une seconde pour Maxime
quand même pourquoi il a pas joué dans
le premier site
mais attends il est peut-être en train
de la tenir allez
il y a perpète là c'est le demi point
sauvé
ouais mais ça fait ça fait tellement
bien celle-là elle fait tellement bien
parce que sans les voir c'est un peu tu
peux tu peux récupérer ça tu peux
récupérer
sur n'importe quel live
donc quand il part il part il part sur
sur des Benoni
genre de
mais parce que d'accord ça vient de
trois
ouais ouais ça vient ça vient de
se cavalier F3 g63 mais après tu es pas
obligé de jouer avec ces 5 non plus je
pense pas que Maxime jouer 4
il en a eu pas mal quand on sait pas qui
va aller à 6 le coup tu sais plutôt Baki
c'était terrible en fait
[Rires]
je sais plus si c'était cavalier à 6 ou
fuj4 mais je pense il en a eu
quelques-unes contre top
donc
alors la Benoni bah ça c'est ça a l'air
de cette bien passé il y a du B5 elle
est belle celle-là
il y a peut-être qui va laisser 3
donc il y a pas de cavaliers à 5 et sur
cavalier D6
avec l'idée dame prend E5
ça doit être bien pour le noir puis on
prend un psy si tu prends F6 c'est ce
qui fait
il va falloir
j'imagine
sur fout des quatre
qui a quand même les fourchettes en F6
ouais là il prend ses 5 inégalise
Dame des 5 et 3 ouais c'est égal ça
va lui prendre
la petite menace d'un Français 5 ça fait
toujours plaisir
que surtout Racer il y a d'en prendre un
deux en plus moi qui va devoir décaler
avec damso bon il fait damso mais là sur
la colonne C il peut avoir quelques
problèmes après le tour C8
[Musique]
est un peu
plus fort que le X 3 mais après il peut
se faire vider la diagonale si réussi à
faire tourner un B3
et jouer B3 mais ça va pas être possible
si il fait un coup comme à 4 et il va
Maxime va jouer B4 et il va poser
problème
ça pas réfléchit longtemps oh là là il a
disparu vite ce pion à deux
ça va
je crois que ça la fertilité là la
dernière la finale
parce que là il fait une partie
elle est pas perdue encore pour lui il a
encore des chances de la tenir mais là
elle est dure pas une belle partie là
quand même on est alors que la deuxième
les deux premières elles étaient
magnifiques
ma tour assez un c'est quand même
je sais comment je vais faire mais en
plus il a aucun coût pour il va tenter
quelque chose mais il refait Toutain ah
mais il laisse B2 maintenant
mais là il fait tout
le puntoa qui fait très mal avec le
fichier 7 on reprend mes 5 à 5 ok ça
part jusque ça s'arrête plus en fait
mais tu arrives tu arrives même pas tu
arrives à l'arrêter où en fait tu peux
faire tourner trois à quatre tour à
trois fou B2 à 3
oui bon
allez ça va égaliser là pour maxi en
plus il a joué vite
ça va me permettre de vraiment me mettre
bien en fait
tout ce qui se passe c'est mal
ok ouais mais là il est bien sorti de
Maxime
il a vraiment fait des coups
bizarres alors
ok là je suis très bien j'ai plus qu'à
j'ai plus qu'à ça c'est assez facile à
gagner non en réalité
mais mec le fouet
je finis mes réglages pendant que c'est
fini oui parce que tu t'échanges une
tour et tu vas pouvoir monter le roi
ça a l'air assez simple
tu vas juste échanger le tour et monter
le roi il a pas fait fou B2 peut-être à
cause de vous c'est un
je sais pas trop ce qu'il espère
pas bien là
non c'est Maxime les noirs
en fait ça se voit au
langage corporel des joueurs
[Musique]
ouais là c'est c'est pas sa pause
ouais ouais c'est à cause des noms qui
c'est qui qui était écrit du mauvais
côté
[Musique]
B2 pour être
les changer une tour c'est peut-être ça
le plus simple
en échangé une et après essayer de
passer le roi jusqu'en C4 et voir
ce genre de truc
s
améliorer le roi mais je trouve que nepo
est quand même très résistant dans le
dans le petit jeu là je sais pas si tu
vois toutes les finales les machins la
première celle-là il met un peu plus de
barbeul que dans un moment
moi mais là il part de trop loin non
mais là il part de trop loin il va pas
la tenir mais je veux dire par là que tu
sens qu'il y a eu du progrès là-dessus
côté n'est pas parce qu'il est en plein
tilt ça aurait pu
ça va pas changer
pour le match
ouais il pose quelques problèmes
techniques quand même
là il laisse du tout dessin non
je trouve qu'il défend extrêmement bien
il est il faut faire attention il a
l'air d'être assez
déterminer
6 puis on prend et tu auras 5 le pion le
pion part pas tout seul
c'est ça c'est un truc en finale qu'il
faut retenir les tours sont toujours
bien derrière les pions pour les deux
joueurs en réalité
c'est pour ça que j'aimais bien quand
même échanger une tour pour tu es assez
tranquille sur ce genre d'attaque allez
tour BK
j'ai pas du tout tout à l'heure j'ai vu
qu'il y avait un tour à 6 qui était
proposé mais j'ai pas de fin c'est juste
pas possible en fait Maxime qui répète
une fois
et il avait 4 il avait 4 ans contre deux
dix hein il avait deux minutes d'avance
j'essaie de
avec le clouage genre peut-être tout
raciste tout rage 5 3G 8 tours G5 à 2
mais ok tu reprends G7 et non mais je
comprends pas en fait bon
[Musique]
en même temps que Maxime mais ça devient
compliqué
et là il veut quoi tour à 4 peut-être
ouais bien joué
OK
et 4 il aura tout reprend des quatre
salaires de passer ça bien joué là bien
joué
ah c'est dur qu'est-ce que ça défend
bien mais pour en gagner une c'était pas
facile bon après il va peut-être pas
aussi bien défendre toutes les parties
il y a
ouais mais il a fait n'importe quoi au
début quand même mais quand tu sais
remis il a très bien
sur foi c'est ça
et si je touche
non j'ai pas mais
non il y a tourgé
d'ailleurs
pour être précis et compter les nuls
mais oui en vrai ça fait un partout
allez ça retourne dans la berlinoise
ouais ça c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
pour Maxime
je suis étonné du choix de nez pour un
comme tu disais mais après
il a peut-être envie de se tester quand
même bah qui sur ses positions là tu as
pas l'air d'être convaincu mais d'un
autre côté peut-être que c'est pour
l'entraînement mais
c'est peut-être pour l'entraînement en
réalité c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
pour Maxime mais tu me diras il joue
quand même en rapide c'est bizarre qui
joue plus parce qu'il joue plus du tout
ça
il a complètement changé
il a complètement et maintenant il joue
Petrov et
berlinois
c'est bizarre qu'il le joue en blitz
dans un truc où il est censé s'amuser
dans quelques mois et il a peut-être
envie de profiter de matchs comme ça
contre du top mondial pour
après contre Ding il va pas trop voir de
4 j'imagine mais bon ouais mais si il
part sur un comme contre parce que
clairement il voulait jouer la terrasse
contre Magnus
ou même d'ailleurs même la Catalane
c'est très c'est le même genre de
position en fait
et là je vous dis 5 bien joué il gagne
un tempo on est plutôt la tour en E2 non
ici avec l'idée de mettre le tour en un
tu vois j'aurais pensé qu'il mettait la
tour en O2
bon là il a égalisé facilement quand
même dans celle-là il va il peut même
jouer avec ses 5 maintenant d'accord
sur la berlinoise ouais c'est vrai que
si tu veux t'entraîner sur la berlinoise
tu vas difficilement trouver mieux que
Maxime
[Musique]
bon pas une partie où il va se passer
grand chose quand même
attends qui est H2 pour que
il peut encore y avoir de la vie bah qui
va faire tout aussi
sept pour pas laisser de cavalier 5
ouais
après j'allais dire est-ce que c'est un
F4 ça peut être dangereux ou pas
tu peux pas jouer F5 parce qu'il y a
cavalier 5 mais une fois que tu as le
fond c'est sec pourquoi pas
il va peut-être se passer des choses
et pourquoi il joue pas fou c'est ça il
a joué
vous avez été déconnecté ok ah bah oui
quand même une
on remballe gros
et ce qui peut vouloir jouer avec toi
qui fait H5 sur damage 5 il veut fouger
3 mais c'est trop
Maxime bien jouer il veut ses 4
[Musique]
oui bah en fait il va se passer des
choses bah qui ça c'est pas nul
maintenant ça y est ni l'un ni l'autre
ne veut faire nul quoi c'est faux
je sais pas je suis pas hyper fan
complexe
mais bon ça reste
égal ça reste dans la normalité
ouais mais on voit que personne veut
personne veut faire mieux personne ne
veut lâcher
et après c'est le genre de position
ouais si dépôt il joue trop relâché il
peut faire une petite il a peut-être
raison Maxime de les jouer celle-là
une époque c'est peut-être le bon client
ça peut l'embêter et qui clique vraiment
au hasard un moment
ouais ça devient plus agréable pour les
blancs quand même je sais pas j'ai
l'impression en tout cas que le cavalier
tu as peut-être un peu plus de potentiel
là tu as peut-être du Tour 6 à Tours
c'est 7 il veut 6
ça donne envie
ouais mais après tu te mets dans le fou
aussi quand même
ça passe pas mais genre la première vue
je pensais que ton C7 c'était tu sais
peut-être dame 8 tours recettes ou truc
comme ça mais non là ça passe pas
parce qu'en plus après le tour C7 il
peut même y avoir des dames G4 peut-être
pas sûr il y aurait dû me prendre
jolie rappelle l'intervention
[Rires]
de temps en temps que j'envoie quand
même une
OK
non en fait il faudrait pas échanger les
dames ici tu vois avec les Blancs
là c'est terrible
mais c'est chaud je reprends à cette
fout des 4 ouais fin torcer deux
par contre si tu as changé de tour c'est
peut-être cool pour les blancs
quoi qu'il arrive avec les blancs en
fait
mais mais que les tours ça va parce que
tu contrôles quand même bien les cases
blanches ok tu peux mettez même pas mis
au blanc moi je pensais que sans les
tours tu étais peut-être même mieux
blanc mais pas vraiment non
[Musique]
là le fou il est trop fort ça va répète
normalement c'est hors des deux là
[Musique]
on a pas un qui veut faire nul
B5 ouais pourquoi pas tu vois il a pas
peur de jouer dame fou contre
les deux ailes les pions ils sont tous
sur cases blanches
c'est tout de suite nette avantage noir
et tu as aussi tous les pions sur blanc
et le foutent case noir donc c'est vrai
que tu contrôle toutes les toutes les
cases du cavalier en réalité il peut pas
s'installer proche de ton roi
qui veut pas échanger mais là six
il veut échanger mais
le cavalier il est bien contrôlé par les
puntos
mais ça tape nulle part en dessin
mais il installe c'est normal il est
bien il peut être défendu facilement par
la dame il peut pas les mettre ça
d'avant B2 Yann là pour essayer c'est ce
qu'il fait j'ai envie de te dire dame à
trois dame B2 et remettre le fond des
quatre son roi il est solide hein
t'arrive pas à le mettre en échec Maximy
va jouer de la modeuse ici
le cavalier en dessin qui l'empêche le
roi d'arriver rapidement donc
incroyable et le cavalier qui vient de
trois dame prend à deux il y a cavalier
des trois bien joué Maxime il l'avait un
Maxime fou B2
fois c'est un fou un fou une époque en
fait
ça ressemble à la 7e partie du match
de match de championnat du monde entre
entre
tu en as aucun des deux qui veut lâcher
mais là attention quand même sur les A4
c'est ton jamais
à Maxime qui défend bien mais une époque
tu vois je le trouve sur les quatre
premières parties là dans le jeu avec
peu de pièces je le trouve très précis
dans ce petit jeu là un peu technique
il fait une grande partie encore il y a
que la troisième là qui était terrible
et puis une partie de la deuxième et il
réussit à jouer plus vite que Maxime ce
qui est pas une mince affaire non plus
mais Maxime qui va du cavalier aussi
maintenant oh un petit dame c'est cinco
peut-être
ça ferait plaisir oh bah ça ferait
plaisir bah oui tu prends non c'est le
coup qu'on attend dame c'est 5
mais il est plus calme qu'avant Yann
c'est plus le genre de
d'erreur qui peut faire en tout cas la
maxime sort lui aussi des grosses
parties mais attention Yann a l'air
d'être un peu au-dessus pour le moment
mais Maxime
c'est un coup qui fait mal
Maxime qui défend bien pour le moment
qui suit mais qui est pas mené au score
et qui attend son heure n'est pas
normalement il va tilt quand même un
moment donné Maxime peut lui prendre
deux trois parties consécutives et faire
tourner le match en sa faveur ouais là
la défense elle est pas facile
il faut peut-être faire dame B2 en fait
et
ou plutôt ou à un je dirais mais
pour cavalier aussi trois F6 parce que
si tu fais dame B2 qui a valu aussi
alors l'ordi d'un gagnant après cavalier
G5 sur wife 6 ah bah voilà tu vois il a
eu le même donc la défense a été pas
facile
on va aller chercher F7 là ça va gagner
ouais
et oui et c'est quand on en parlait un
époque qui jouait très bien mais qui
peut craquer là Maxime il peut peut-être
lui en prendre une autre derrière et
faire la diff bon là c'est maintenant
monsieur
allez elle fait du bien la maxime qui
souffle ouais mais Maxime qui a trouvé
le très joli
il a très très bien défendu allez c'est
bien là c'est exactement ce qu'il
fallait n'est pas qui qui domine mais
qui qui rond
et Maxime en contre qui a réussi à en
prendre une
et là les points peuvent s'enchaîner la
salade pour Maxime elle est importante
il peut il peut éventuellement mettre un
deuxième point à la mettre un peu la
tête sous l'eau ayan est-ce que Yann
peut lâcher une petite info dans la
prépa là sur la grunefeld
prends-toi tu es vraiment un renard à
qui en fait il est juste là pour pour
choper des prépas Championnat du Monde
en tilt ça peut hein
maintenant c'est parti sur une grande
une grande fête avec tour B1 c'est ce
que je jouais
[Musique]
ma jeunesse
c'est encore théorique là ou pas parce
que ça pourrait c'est sûr c'est encore
la théorie quoi c'est
souvent on donne le pion au 7 pour
partir avec le pion a j'en ai eu
tellement des parties comme ça
c'est trop bien il veut quoi il veut
cavalier froid GF et jouer les pions
doublés devant le rock mais contrôler la
grande diagonale ouais mais ça c'est
très tranquille pour Maxime c'est le
genre de truc vraiment très tranquille
là il y a beaucoup de coups
prises
2 à 4
tout de suite quoi que ok
il part pour ça
[Musique]
ok attention un petit peu quand même
du coup ça lui permet surtout rien
d'avoir
tu auras 8 il fait tourner simplement
oh bien joué ça pour dame G5 mais il va
faire H4 non hk94
un parti
ça va trop vite ça va trop vite pour
nous surtout
oui en fait ça va juste à une vitesse
normale pour eux mais nous on n'a pas le
temps de suivre
parce que là c'est le prix d'un coup
quand même le prix d'un coup il est très
depuis deux trois coups il est il est
cher
ça méritait quand même petite réflexion
il y avait même du dame 3 d'ailleurs
c'est Maxime ouais
ça va
faire tout à 7 logique ok mais ça c'est
nul non mais un peu chiant ou pas du
tout chiant ça c'est toi je te demande
au spécialiste de la finale bah qui
voilà ça se calcule c'est pas
il peut faire un tour B2 je pense là
il fallait juste éviter F4 donc soit
tour B2 pour taper F2 soit tour B3
et là
il va tenter tout rouge je crois G4 F4
bien joué Maxime encore rocher
alors
attention parce que maintenant il y a du
F5 aussi donc
[Musique]
ici je crois que c'est un Maxime il
attend
Maxime qui subit légèrement mais qui
défend extrêmement bien là il a fait une
grosse partie de défense là et qui est
qui en contre sur la moindre faute de
Yann il essaie de le punir
Yann qui prend l'initiative du jeu pour
le moment mais qui réussit pas
à faire vaciller Maxime
mais là Maxime tu vois qu'il laisse
cette opportunité il était pas obligé il
pouvait jouer F5 et quelques coups avant
et là il laisse tomber deux et roi G4
avec l'idée F4
que puis on prend roi apprend tora3 il y
aurait du F3
possibilité quoi ça reste nul mais tu
vas devoir défendre
ouais c'est pour ça que je préférais tu
vois juste F5 un peu avant pour mais bon
ici il va trouver Torcéen et sur F4
qu'est-ce qu'il va Maxime
B4
et puis on prend F4
dans le Tour
b43 tours G2 est-ce qu'il veut
Saint-Maxime je sais pas il va falloir
faire quand même gaffe un truc comme
tour B7 3 F8 tour B8 pour essayer
d'aller faire tour à chute et protéger
le pion par derrière
je sais pas un Baki c'est pas l'ordi du
tout là c'est moi qui calcule
c'est comme ça qu'on cherche ça peut
être je sais pas du tout si ça peut
passer par derrière là comme ça
ok ça va être intéressant
ah mais il peut juste GF en fait
oui bon c'est facile
ok bien joué en tout cas
le dame G5 était il fallait
il fallait le jouer le DAB G5 très bien
joué un de la part de Maxime
nous on était parti dans un délire après
et là ça va là ça va signer
F4
je jouais tout H4
et attendre tu crains rien non trois
contre trois comme ça
bah il est quand même un petit peu enfin
les pions ils sont plus avancés pour les
blancs donc faut faire un tout petit peu
attention mais ici F4
ou F4 tourage 3 roi des quatre tours F3
d'ailleurs
on va peut-être même se retrouver à
jouer le gars un moment donné comme dans
les parties précédentes
oui mais c'est déjà comme tu dis c'est
déjà les blancs qui défendent de près
il est pas complètement fou
ça va
il a l'air il a récuré là n'est pas il
arrive pas à gagner Maxime qui défend
trop bien
est-ce que ce serait pas déjà la pause
OK
[Musique]
la pause Baky quand même et donc on est
encore en est-ce qu'on est encore en
5 + 1 ah bah oui
tu pensais que tu étais que tu étais où
c'est ça la question
important la petite pause
on va s'arrêter dommage de pas l'avoir
celle-là quand même un petit 10 minutes
là pour bien souffler
c'est beau ce que c'est la preuve qui a
vraiment personne qui en est content
quoi les joueurs ça sent qu'ils ont
encore envie de jouer
ah bah ça vous permet de prendre votre
billet pour la Beck up
qui est très très mal j'espère que tu as
pris la poule présidentielle quand même
j'espère qu'il a tout pris hein est-ce
que le capitaine of ses lunettes ou son
qui love ses lunettes de soleil est-ce
qu'il fait une roue des lunettes de
soleil pour sa poule
je sais pas ce qu'il fait en fait
je peux pas je veux pas te dire je sais
pas ce qu'il fait attends j'essaie de
mettre le time
je sais pas si l'offrira quelque chose
je sais pas pourquoi
mon chronomètre marche pas attends
[Musique]
en tout cas c'est bien parti pour Maxime
3 2
[Musique]
j'ai regardé mes parties de title là il
y a pas longtemps
quelques quelques trucs intéressants
et je regarde en général les parties de
title des plus forts joueurs
mais ça dépend il y en a qui sont plus
intéressants que d'autres là peut-être
que le tour B1 de Yann
il est plus intéressant que son que ces
deux premières parties avec les Blancs
parce que comme il est sous pression il
a décidé de jouer une petite idée quand
même
tu penses qu'il essaye de
vie qui pousse tu joues est-ce que tu
joues la poule présidentielle ou la
poule capitaine l'autre veggie
mais ce qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui
ont pris leur
leur billet là dans le chat pour ce
grand tournoi est-ce que ludique peut
remettre mais il remet le lien est ce
que tu peux remettre le lien de chats
comme aussi peut-être remplir la poule
du presse ou le
ce qu'on a dans le chat bitstream le 49e
inscrit qui
qui gagne le mode dédicacé quand même
pris de la poule présidentielle
tous les liens
c'est quand c'est dimanche
10 je crois samedi 10 samedi 10 samedi
10 décembre
la consommation de nourriture et de
boisson venant de l'extérieur de
l'espace est interdit de bouteilles
d'eau interdite ben il faudrait que tu
achètes sur place pour
c'est quand même normal hein comme dans
tous les endroits
petit système suisse ou pas ce sera un
système suisse
Paris Première arrondissement
lispote c'est à 5 minutes à pied du
Louvre
le 10 décembre je suis à Disney
est-ce que la poule du capitaine serait
pas déjà plus forte que ma poule
moi je pense que personne va aller dans
ta poule en fait ça le problème
pas spectateur justement pour les
boissons dans alcoolisées ouais mais
frérot le problème c'est que
ben tu pourras en acheter une de
boissons alcoolisées si tu souhaites
parce que ce sera en vente mais on peut
pas
il y a des réalités économiques
malheureusement
est-ce que les spectateurs qu'on dit
avoir l'occasion de faire un petit
selfie avec le président j'imagine mais
je vous conseille si vous venez de enfin
pour moi en priorité il faut prendre une
place spectateur
et après place joueur et plutôt les deux
à mon avis
et malheureusement vous pouvez pas
prendre les trois quoi ça ça fait mal
les trois on peut pas
alors que moi je peux prendre les trois
non
[Rires]
ce qu'on va acheter ton livre et le
faire dédicacer j'ai envie de te dire
oui mais bon c'est il y aura beaucoup de
faudra que tu me trouves un moment libre
comment on fait pour se qualifier en car
parfois tu joues un des deux tournois et
que tu essaies de te qualifier mais
garder vos questions pour la prochaine
pause on va profiter du match qui
reprend et de cette nouvelle berlinoise
Baki
qui rejoue la berlinoise
incroyable la même ligne bon tu me diras
il a pas eu de problème sur la dernière
mais ouais Maxime qui change qui joue le
cavalier C3 et ça suit déjà côté Yann il
a l'air complètement dégoûté
pourquoi j'ai pas joué une française
c'est dur de jouer ces lignes en blitz
quand tu quand tu connais pas trop
et puis pendant des heures en plus
mais alors il va choisir laquelle vous
êtes ou qui donne les deux fous
et il donne les deux fous
en fait peut-être qu'il a complètement
au hasard là la berlinoise
ça c'est quand même un avantage blanc à
long terme non
ouais bon après c'est minime tu as trois
lignes dans la berlinoise au féminine
donc c'est celle là ouais avec F5
tasses bon il y en a deux avec la paire
de fou c'est vraiment minime pour les
blancs et celle où on a la tour avec le
pion isolé mais bon
les trois sont ok
c'est tellement pas envie ah bon ça tu
as pas envie de la jouer celle-là
je sais pas comment tu vas
et on joue pas alors la bonne question
dans le chat on met le pion en Détroit
et pas en D4 parce que sinon cavalier 8
pourrait arriver en E4
ça me fait penser aussi de ça que c'est
ce scandinave avec le pion des trois que
tu m'avais joué d'ailleurs qui sont
assez pénis parce que ça bloque le fou
des fois le parfois le pion est mieux
placent des trois camps des 4 parce
qu'il contrôle dans la prisme
pardon il faut que je remette d'ailleurs
j'ai remettre mon setup il a fait dame
français 7 j'ai vu j'ai vu il laisse
dame prend F5 mais la cavalier au 4 qui
est épreuve 2 j'imagine ouais alors
attends faut que je remette tout réussis
tout ré 8 il va tout échanger mettre le
pion en G6 c'est assez égalisant non
quand même
un petit moment la défendre quand même
après tout aussi parce que tour 8 on
peut
avant sur dame pro F5 il y avait
cavalier 4 c'est ça
quand tu dois commencer à jouer des
coups comme G6 c'est déjà assez
désagréable ouais non mais j'avais pas
vu le j'avais pas eu la ref de
du Tour ce 8 qui passait pas j'avais
j'étais dans une fausse idée ouais donc
là c'est mieux pour les blancs tout
romain et surtout 8 il y a tout reprend
F6
ok il fait tout F8 j'avais tout reprend
F6 qui gagne une pièce donc il fait tour
C8 mais là on sent que ça peut ah le
pion à 7 qui tombe déjà tu reprends 8
tours
donc c'est presque un punto là
mauvaise ouverture pour pour Yann ça
fait déjà trois fois qu'il se fait il
arrive pas s'il veut tester la
berlinoise il a vu
là il a vu c'est pas pour lui bon on a
toujours su mais bon
mais là ça prouve
et s'il fait cavalière
il peut pas faire cavalier prend 8
il a pas envie non plus peut-être il
peut même y avoir des coups comme
une bêtise bah simplement peut-être dame
3 d'ailleurs
au moins tu perds pas le pion ouais non
mais tu es obligé mais là tu es bon tu
as pas très envie quand même quoi non tu
es complètement dégoûté mais c'est
peut-être ta meilleure chance d'âme
c'est ça qui est des six
tu tiens encore mais il va y avoir du C4
un quelque part pour ouvrir peut-être
tout de suite
tu vas être très mal mais bon l'autre
j'ai l'impression que c'était juste
perdant techniquement en ligne quoi non
non bien sûr bien sûr là il faut jouer
deux trois bon coup avec les Blancs pour
mettre pression encore mais oui
l'ouverture c'est un succès encore au
Maxime et berlinoise qui se passe bien
mais là il laisse peut-être cavalier F6
dame D4 dame G7
pour ça peut-être ton coup d'AMS C5 il
était pas mal mais ok c'est 4 juste pour
info l'ordi donner dame G5 pour rentrer
vite
mais là par contre l'ordi donne gagnant
avec un seul coup c'est dames ces cinq
maintenant ok ok c'est hyper dur dame
c'est 5 c'est dur parce que le coup
d'avant tu l'as refusé et là il faut le
voir
il devait jouer le dépenser
bien aussi comme quoi c'était avantage
mais la dame c'est 5 c'est ouais c'est
hyper fort
c'est compliqué c'est pression encore
et pourquoi dame c'est 5 les dames 5
c'était juste de faire tout recettes en
fait juste au coup d'avant il y avait
qu'il y avait des six qui couvraient et
là comme le cavalier était venu à FC
c'était plus fort Roissy 7
elle est dur mais puis on prend des 5
puis on prend des cinq
ouais
c'est pour ça que ça peut tenir pour les
Noirs mais on voit qu'il y a beaucoup de
faiblesses quand même après si réussi à
faire roi F7 petit à petit va colmater
s'il enlève le roi de son trou et oui il
va réussir peut-être à égaliser grosse
défense de Yann
dans ce match quand même que le joueur
qui a l'initiative a toujours du mal à
terminer les deux joueurs défendent très
bien je trouve
et là il faut qu'il mette son fouet en
jeu peut-être G3 du coup tu auras dire
tout aussi
donc toi aussi c'est un peu bizarre mais
bon après
c'est pas facile avec les blancs de
prouver de prouver l'avantage comme ça
après faut pas qu'il s'en parle comme la
u feyan faut qu'il accepte aussi
peut-être Maxime là que qu'il est pas
réussi à conclure et pas qu'ils se
retrouvent dans une finale
attention parce que fou contre le
cavalier faut faire ah oui parce que si
tu as les pions c'est qui s'échangent je
suis trop trouver à mettre le pion D4
que le cavalier il tournicode qui te le
gagne pour faire gaffe plus qu'une
disque contre 2 33 là c'est
si on prend la pendule en compte on est
proche des gars maintenant bien joué
puis on prend des cinq ça améliore la
structure
des 8 et là il va pouvoir faire cavalier
prend attention
ça clique des deux côtés à une vitesse
c'est pas possible en fait
là ça
c'est
peut-être dame G7 ici j'ai 7 il faut les
avoir accrochés mais c'est peut-être un
très gros coup
je pense que d'habitude c'est bon comme
d'ici là
c'est pas facile à jouer c'est cool
j'essaie il faut avoir la foi quand même
ouais mais bon tu as une bonne pièce
pour les blancs c'est la dame 5 tu t'en
débarrasses
et tourner 7 et là il y a pas fougée
d'eux simplement
c'est quoi
le coup pour égalité
mais ici il y a peut-être encore
il y a plus il y a cavalier C7 seul coup
pour égalité
[Musique]
que j'avais pas vu non plus oui parce
que maintenant bah en fait
il trouve qu'il y a ces 7 tours F6 d'un
Mosset attention ça peut être même bien
pour les Noirs
il y a peut-être
on en parlait un de cette partie qui
pouvait
c'est un peu dommage parce qu'il avait
de nouveau les blancs
c'est n'importe quoi c'est pas possible
en fait
avec les noirs
c'est Maxime qui au blanc ils arrivent
pas à voir les bonnes couleurs
tchaikohead
c'est pas possible reine
mais bon c'est beau
là il faut quelqu'un du staff de chescom
lance la partie c'est le meilleur moment
du match là quand même ah bah oui ah bah
attends il y a hier il y a quand même
une déco
il y a quand même grishu qui a perdu la
partie qui est un peu fait tourner le
match sur déco
il peut encore y avoir des trucs encore
plus beau que ça
c'est la c'est rien encore Baki on est
pas au clou du spectacle
le chrono je sais pas si le chrono
officiel tourne ou pas
ah non cette fois-ci c'est les bonnes
couleurs malheureusement j'aurais bien
aimé que ça refasse ah et quoi trop les
peau qui en a profité ah à gambiro ah
sympa bah qui ça un gambiroit
mais il le joue assez souvent quand même
je sais mais parce qu'il joue vite ça
fait toujours plaisir de voir un Gambie
roi quand même par principe
mais avec les noirs
qui sont encore sur Youtube
au troisième coup écoute moi j'aime bien
les blancs là je sais pas si c'est une
prépa de Maxime mais ça je prends les
blancs tous les jours
tu as quand même les pions au Santa le
développement facile je sais pas ce que
ça donne l'évaluation
ça a l'air plus facile à jouer avec les
Blancs
tu as plus d'espace faites c'est ce que
tu attends quand tu joues dans le miroir
en tout cas quand même parce qu'il a
souvent joué en rapide ou en blitz
quand on nous demande sur la chaîne
est-ce que le Gambie Roy est jouable etc
alors en partie longue c'est censé être
réfuter c'est pas l'eau mais c'est censé
aller pour plus que bien aller pour les
Noirs mais vous voyez qu'en Blitz même
contre un joueur du top mondial préparé
qui aime VL il a quand même une position
intéressante Yann donc oui le gambiroit
c'est une ouverture jouable bah qui
en surprise mais il faut avoir bien
préparé avec les Blancs parce qu'en fait
tu fais une petite erreur et tu es tout
de suite très mal quand même
par là c'est même c'est en semi surprise
là qui le joue
ouais max pouvait un peu s'y attendre
mais après à quel point il a préparé je
ne sais pas
en tout cas intéressant de voir cette
ouverture bon là Maxime c'est
complètement remis il a réussi à
récupérer son petit problème d'espace
et oui il a fait un même fait un cours
sur chez sable sur le Gambier roi Yann
joueur de Gambie roi avant tout
et là les pièces de Maxime qui se place
il y a toujours cette faiblesse entre
sur le roi blanc à cause de l'absence du
pion F bah qui bah là on a vu que Maxime
il a gagné un maximum de tempo quand
même depuis le début de la partie
d'ailleurs tout revient tourner un Fuji
F4 G3 F2 ok c'est trop donc sans ces
problèmes de
[Musique]
sans ces problèmes de développement il a
plus il est ok là Maxime
et c'est compliqué comme position c'est
équilibre et c'est compliqué chacun des
deux joueurs à des arguments à faire
valoir
est-ce qu'il peut pas jouer là il y a
plusieurs possibilités plutôt prendre en
dessin que je dirais pour mettre le fond
en dessin
mais céder il va sûrement jouer cavalier
prend cavalier prendre pour prendre
[Musique]
ça va être là
pour trouver un coup quoi
j'ai trois intermédiaire
j'ai trois c'est tellement bizarre c'est
le coup serait même pas venu à l'esprit
en fait non
de se faire kiffer n'est pas quand même
sur certains
là il est obligé d'ailleurs
au même
mais oui cavalier prend c'est ce que tu
vas devoir faire tu as pas tout reprend
il y avait cavalier H4 qui va les
prendre
c'était pas possible
elle a une belle position là Maxime
le roi le roi blanc est faible après
alors après attention parce que les
finales elles peuvent être compliquées
le roi blanc est faible mais si ça part
en final le roi blanc il est plus proche
du centre quand même
on en est loin encore de cette finale
malheureusement le cavalier 6 peut pas
intervenir ouais
on en est loin mais tu sais un vide un
échec en D8 vit un truc enfin c'est il
faut faire attention à ça en tout cas
avec le noir on en est loin sans en être
loin quoi c'est ce que tu veux dire
dans ce match
de toujours du mal à évaluer ses
positions personnellement
attention au final et attention car il
existe faut le remettre en jeu des qui
peut Maxime il est mal placé ce cavalier
il veut peut-être t'envoyer du H4 non
jouer
dame dessin qui va prendre et il va
faire mieux
sinon il veut cavalier 5 maintenant
qu'il a cloué le cheval
pour ou H4 d'ailleurs parce que
[Musique]
de l'autre côté
qui seraient en train d'essayer de jouer
cavalier F3 prend le 5 2 3 fois entendre
le bip de dire non non
et dire Rennes
et maintenant les finales elles
deviennent à double tranchant aussi
j'arrive finalement une bonne structure
à l'ailera maintenant Maxime j'arrive
pas à comprendre si Neto il joue comme
ça parce que c'est le speechesse et
qu'il a envie de se faire kiffer ou
est-ce qu'il joue comme ça parce qu'il
joue comme ça et pour un bar en fait
parce que c'est quand même kiffant de
jouer comme ça
on nous dit dans le chat le tourage 5
pour tout pour avoir des idées de Tours
à chien le problème c'est que la tour
elle est trop excentrée là-bas aussi
avec cavalier 5
il retire ce problème
en fait attends
il y aura pas de rois G6 éventuellement
pour essayer de jouer le gain c'est trop
roi je suis
toujours
dame G4
ça va faire nul ouais mais c'est beau
roi J6 quand même
pas essayer une entoureuse ça
va jouer la finale de pion et qui vont
quand même essayer de la gagner
est-ce que ce serait pas jouable en fait
en vrai
est-ce que c'est pas mieux au noir quand
même parce que si tu vas manger les
pions il y en a plus de l'autre côté
ouais il fait tour des trois mais
attends c'est pas pion de plus ça si ça
va finir en deux contre un mais c'est
nul facile et torbédo quand même
est-ce que c'est si nul que ça ça
va être obligé de jouer à 5 à un moment
en fait je vais pas faire
si on fait à 5 et qu'on liquide tous les
pions non mais bref 6 3g25
les rois des 5 rois français 5 non c'est
pas juste gagnant ça
il y a peut-être C6 encore mais ouais
non mais il se rapproche il se rapproche
du gain
c'est coup de balle ouais mais attends
mais là ça ressemble à gagner il y a pas
G5 on reprend à 7 G4
ça doit gagner aussi
et maintenant
c'est qui part
et la finale de pion elle devait être
nulle quand même mais elle devait pas
être facile
elle était désagréable mais la finale de
Tours je pense qu'elle était nulle c'est
juste il devait quand même C5 ça devait
être terrible comme
fallait réfléchir un peu quoi un peu de
précision mais là c'est facile
c'est deux trois
ou C2
dans les deux sens
de toute façon tu oui
tu peux pas manger ces deux ce que la
finale de pion est perdante donc
qui se fait sortir allez c'est peut-être
le moment là de faire le break avec les
Blancs Maxime
c'est pas possible
moi je te dis qu'il se teste au moins il
revoit toutes ces variantes
je sais pas parce que vous aussi c'est
là c'est quand même une variante qui est
pas terrible
c'est complètement de la merde
terrible c'est pas terrible il faut
aussi
fou ces quatre j'ai jamais vu ça dans
la berlinoise
j'ai jamais vu
je me suis refait déconnecter de
cheesecom
en fait c'est pas bien en fait
cavalier D4 j'aurais plus vu ça quelques
cavalier F4 mais bon cavalier D4
pro
il met la pression sur les tours et
prendre tout reprendre B5 peut-être
encore et sur B3 C3
tape un
tour de lui et toi bien joué
mais
ça peut pas aller ça non non ça va pas
du tout ça c'est quoi ce placement de
pièces les fous C4 et B4 ils sont
tellement moche
bah là il y a sûrement ces trois et B3
quoi que ces trois fausses C5 B3 full
dessin
d'avoir minci à la caméra on dit ça dans
le chat c'est je m'étais pas fait le
rapprochement
mais donne l'impression d'avoir perdu
quelques kilos quand même
il y a pas que là
[Musique]
je pense que cavalier 5 c'est un bon
calibre 5 il y a une petite chose en
début d'après
oui
on peut pas faire qui est Prim F5 il y
aura toujours des 8 mats côté noir n'est
pas qui va devoir jouer tour G8
et après il y a pas un c3b4 pour chasser
le foot case noir et gagner en E7
ça met la pression qu'il y a 5 peut-être
que c'est un cavalier
prise foot dessin qui va les prendre G7
fois 6
ça a l'air d'être gagnant de partout
bah oui pas facile la défendre après
cavalie F5 je pensais pas que
je pensais pas que c'était si fort en
fait quand je l'ai proposé c'était plus
pour échanger en recette avoir une belle
une belle finale mais là ça ressemble de
plus en plus à gagnant
la finale avantageuse mais là ça
ressemble à gain direct non ouais parce
que j'ai 8 a raison juste à trois
peut-être juste à trois par exemple H6
mais bon ABG qui allait prendre
ses 5 et il peut y avoir du Fou de aussi
ok leur dit regarde comment il défend il
fait à trois pousser 5 B4 fous 6
à 3
B5 tour F4 non ça a l'air pas mal pour
Maxime après il peut faire des 5
peut-être
B5 est sur B3
et c'est 5 maintenant sur B3
ok c'est dur
ouais dans ce sens là
5 pour torturer quoi pas pour gagner
tout de suite
c'est ça après il y aurait le cavalier
enfermé en G8 c'est 5 cavaliers Pro 7
puis on prend des 4 cavaliers 8
et ici avec les deux fous bon c'est
qu'est-ce qui se passe là les folle
cette partie cavalier des deux
ok c'est nul je pense c'est ça au
minimum
l'ordi donne fous prend à deux avantages
noirs
cavalier prend que fou prend à deux
joli coup aussi elle se soit les deux
derniers coups de Maxime ils ont été
limites
Bobby Fisher aussi quand même oui
ça aurait pu
mais il va faire quoi il va faire [ __ ]
puis on prend G5 cavaliers à 5 ok c'est
complexe c'est quand même mieux blanc
non
structure est tellement dégueu et tu as
même pas de matériel en moins
c'est peut-être si tu cliques au hasard
tu peux jouer fous prendre
[Musique]
faut prendre vite c'est pas très dur
pour Maxime il y aura encore
c'est presque fin du match ça quand il
peut jouer un coup pareil
il est encore long ce match quand même
bacy attention et ça fait deux points
d'écart
mais tu pouvais pas jouer fou prend à
deux non plus en fait
tu pouvais pas mais faut prendre des
deux ok c'est juste pas possible
c'est quand même costaud hein une fois
que tu l'as vu c'est pas facile
il peut déjà savoir mais il peut
vérifier il a le temps
mais vous pouvez aussi cette tour est
fuite
tu peux prendre en D2 tu peux tout enfin
non
c'est trop fou prendre des deux
il va trouver Maxime ça va faire deux
points d'écart
même ça ça ressemble à bien fu H4 puis
on prend F6 non
ici il y a plus on prend 5
paraissait enfin il y a tout qui
paraissait bien pour les blancs mais
faut même si c'était assez facile
bizarre ne devait pas s'attendre bah tu
vois il a pas pu en prendre ça mais
attends c'est loin c'est loin d'être
fait la c'est hyper compliqué
voilà je pense qu'après puis on prend F6
gfg36
ça ressemble à bien pour le blanc
ouais mais c'est pas c'est pas signé
c'est ce que je veux dire par là
ok ça c'était le coup main de l'ordi
d'ailleurs peut-être que plus on prend
il faut prendre vite c'était même pas si
clair tu as raison ça c'est bien joué 5
et il va taper le pion le pion moi le
fois 4 je l'écoute Maxime surtout G5
menace x 3 il y a 3 4
qui clou et qui empêche fouet 3
très jolie aussi
je pense qu'il va être obligé de tenter
mais F5 l'ordi donne tour D7 quand on
reprend G7 mais c'est tour des 7 pareil
qu'est-ce qu'il fait
ça a l'air assez facile quand même pour
Maxime maintenant
attention quand même
B3 il faut toujours faire gaffe contre
ces joueurs baquis quand même tout le
temps
un petit betterait
B2 et il y a pas ton français 5 à cause
de fous des quatre mais ils sont
insupportables
moi ils me font peur ces gens et regarde
il veut prendre CB et faire A4 non même
pas je pensais que vous les CB CB A4 ton
français 7 vous prend B2 et jouer
elle était intéressante
il avait peut-être une chance d'ailleurs
avec ça
il est pas du tout après l'ordi de n'est
pas du tout ce que j'ai dit ce que je
viens de dire là c'était ouais mais ça a
l'air intéressant
ok mais
ça c'est ce que c'est facile
ça c'est nul
c'est trop cette partie et là la
technique c'est d'aller dans le coin à
huit Maxime d'ailleurs qui qui essaye
même pas fois c'est trop hein
mais c'était pas simple à qui
je pense que si je jouais B3 et qu'après
G4 c'était fini tout de suite je pense
ouais mais à trois c'était ça
jouait ah bah voilà une petite une
petite neige d'or quand même côté Maxime
trop fort
depuis longtemps ce Tour européen
c'est sa variante principale contre la
nage d'or
en tout cas les deux hommes qui jouent à
un niveau stratosphérique l'un comme
l'autre
dessin là
ressemble un petit peu mieux pour les
blancs
va les prendre
bizarre de pas jouer
après ça reste ouais il a la case F4
Maxime alors ça c'est une déposition de
nage d'offre un peu compliqué parce
qu'on a l'impression que c'est très bien
pour les blancs mais en fait c'est pas
clair
il est obligé de rendre le fou il rend
le fou
pas de souci
[Musique]
c'est bizarre il joue pas
ils ont 4 minutes 30 chacun c'est fou
après les ouvertures c'est toujours
spécial dans ces matchs tu peux pas
vraiment jouer tes trucs principaux ni
l'un ni l'autre
ouais en tout cas il sort bien là de
cette ouverture Maxime
c'est bien là il a il a bien fait de
changer le ganbiroual avait quand même
posé lui posé quelques problèmes
bien joué sur f6f4
c'était anticipé
[Musique]
ok mais ça c'est un peu mieux pour les
blancs non
il a peut-être pas il a peut-être dû
réfléchir un peu avant de laisser jouer
ce F4
quel niveau de jeu en tout cas quand tu
quand tu vois le match d'hier d'ingrichu
que c'était c'était du même acabit ses
joueurs sont vraiment au dessus du reste
qui c'est
la BK
ça pose des gros problèmes
regarde la structure comme elle a fait
comme elle tourne allez regarde ce pion
4 sur la mauvaise fin il était obligé de
le mettre c'est pas facile à gérer pour
les noirs avec si peu de temps c'est
très dur c'est le f6f4 qui a fait mal
mais il va défendre sa maxime non
ouais ouais mais bon c'est ok tu parles
d'un truc ou tu dois pas être moins bien
et là tu suis quand même
ouais pas facile je sais pas comment
défendre ça
là tu es sûr
en pratique c'est très dur très très dur
en pratique de défendre ça
mais il a aussi envie d'échanger les
dames je pense non
la dame G5 c'est pas mal mais H4 il doit
faire dameset il va revenir d'un autre
croix n'y peut pas laisser jouer E3
quand même des pots trois ça fait quand
même tourner la partie doit être obligé
de 7 il va faire dame 3 et dame 5 qui va
revenir
et il va revenir sur une autre idée que
de jouer dame C3 il va jouer peut-être
ou je veux
il y a pas H5 d'un proche
[Musique]
et il veut peut-être faire ses six
maintenant
mais ça c'est très très dur pour les
pour Maxime ça va pas être
fondé
il s'occupe que de 4 mais il s'occupe
plus de C et s'évapartir
d'ailleurs il essaie de revenir
mais là c'est dur hein quand le furieux
il y a des tours c'est 5 tu reprends F5
il faut prendre E4 aussi il y avait une
course 5 attention encore des 5 là
[Musique]
mais sur là surtout C8 tours C5 il y a
la petite tactique comme tu dis tu
reprends le 5 d'un prime 4 avec louage
qui arrive et c'était très dur à jouer
qui a changé
les deux côtés un Maxime qui défend bien
aussi mais nepo c'est ouais mais les
deux sont impressionnants c'est un
niveau de jeu
à partir de F4 il a été très
impressionnant sur cette partie
c'est c'est parti impressionnantes
quand il y a trop de coups ici
c'est hyper fort c'est 7 ça a l'air bien
aussi et d'un F4 ouais c'est
fou H3 sur G6
après c'est pas d'ailleurs louper un
pari il va pas être content quand Maxime
va aller jouer au 3
il y avait peut-être pris des tours et 6
ou un truc comme ça
dame j'ai 5 et peut-être bien joué 5
flûte
je sais pas moi j'avais dame ranger 5
qui me paraissait gagnant pour les
blancs mais ok
mais bon tu as pas d'échec
ça joue pas mal là
c'est
qui part
peut-être la meilleure chance pour
tenter de jouer le gain c'est Dame prend
le 4 mais il y aura pris c'est si c'est
dommage 5 damder
et attention Yann qui relève passer un
demi point là Maxime qui avait raté le
coche dans la partie précédente penser
que ne peut égaliserait cette fois-ci
c'est Maxime qui défend au top
tension c'est quand même pas
complètement fini trois il y a fou B7
encore
c'est bien joué attention
recette il va faire torcer 5 peut-être
essayer de gratter un pion attention
un tour des 8 E3
non non
des deux côtés
[Musique]
je me fais redéconnecter de cheescom je
sais pas ce qui t'arrive va qui c'est
range qui veut pas que tu commentes en
fait
donc règle le problème juste
quoique incroyable
ah ouais non mais le niveau de jeu en
défense
le tour des trois bien joué encore il
fait roi de 7 assez précis
ah non ils sont beaucoup trop forts
non mais là il y a des séquences quand
même de
très très haut niveau
et 5 2
3 il va faire [ __ ] prend deux mais bon
là ça devrait aller roi français 7 ça
devrait aller cette fois-ci
incroyable
mais il y a quand même mais là ouais la
défense de Maxime
mais que en attaque jamais en défense
quasiment
en défense c'est
je sais pas comment ils font en fait
parce que voir que le roi E7 roi des 6
il y avait le tour prend des 7 machin et
tout qui gagnait c'est impressionnant
moi j'ai compris juste parce que c'était
pas dans les coups de l'ordi du coup
j'ai essayé de comprendre comment
réfuter j'ai compris mais sinon j'aurais
jamais trouvé
Maxime qui va essayer de mater
attends ça reste complexe là
c'est terrible
et il y a un époque qui a écrit un truc
dans le chat ah non il a proposé nul
pardon
je sais pas si encore une game parce que
le chrono vu les pauses les machins je
sais pas comment ils ont compté ça
allez c'est non ça y est c'est fini
c'était la dernière de la cadence mais
c'est pas la dernière pause
oh que non
c'est pas la dernière c'est le plus
important
ouais
ça prend les 200 g chez
parti bon il doit être content d'avoir
une petite pause quand même
ça fait toujours plaisir
il a perdu le bide on sera peut-être pas
pour lui au match Championnat du Monde
Baki
ah bah ouais là c'est Vlad il va te dire
bon bah Ding du coup non mais il a
compris
là il peut gagner quoi
il récupère toute son énergie
tu penses quoi de ce match qui est
favori là après après cette première
section
Maxime quand même qui mène d'un point
c'est pas assez anecdotique comme écart
où tu où ça reste 55 ans
quand même donc je pense que Maxime il
est favori
combien tu donnes 65 35 pas plus
au moins
je pense que les gros favoris là
Maxime
après faut aussi se dire que ne pas
jouer un peu plus vite sur les parties
donc peut-être avec moins de temps il
sera favorisé
ou pas
ouais mais après je trouve que le par
exemple celle où Maxime il a trouvé le
dame C7 la finale qu'il a tenu là le
[Musique]
et même certains tu vois le gang miroir
comment Yann il a choisi un moment de
faire des G3 tout ça attention quand il
quand il va pas avoir beaucoup de temps
ça peut être dur pour lui aussi mais ça
peut se payer cash contre Maxime qui a
l'air d'être très affûté aujourd'hui
tactiquement ouais Maxime il s'est
préparé pour le pour le pour le match ça
se voit il a l'air il a l'air d'être en
grande forme bah qui j'en profite pour
rappeler que le 10 décembre on organise
le tournoi à la backup qui aura lieu à
Paris rue de Rivoli à
partir de 14 heures avec la grande
finale à 20h il y a deux tournois à 14h
et 17h vous pouvez vous inscrire vous
aurez la chance de jouer éventuellement
contrebaki enfin moi j'ai la chance j'ai
pas le rencontrer en tournoi Baki mais
peut-être certains seront contents de
jouer contre lui 17h le deuxième tournoi
et à 20h la grande finale il y a des
places spectateurs aussi pour suivre le
match et on disait tout faire dans le
chat mais j'espère que dans quelques
années de ça on aura la chance de suivre
des matchs quand même vel n'est pas dans
des
des lieux et on pourra les encourager
avec les deux hommes devant nous mais
mais donc ce sera le 10 décembre pas
spectateurs à partir de 20h pour suivre
les cartes de finale demi-finale finale
et les deux tournois avant 14h17h il y a
Ludwig qui va mettre les liens dans le
chat n'hésitez pas il reste plus
énormément de place
il descendent
qui préfère me rencontrer à 14h que à 2h
du matin
[Rires]
je suis d'accord mais bon même à 4
heures dans une muret éclairée ça fait
quand même peur en fait même sur un
boulevard éclairé ça peut mettre très
mal
il y aura deux zones de jeux il y aura
deux zones de jeux ouais
inscrit à la poule présidentielle de 14
heures gagne
le mug dédicacé
de 49e
c'est un des prix est-ce que ça serait
pas un des
plus beaux prix c'est peut-être le
drapeau
utilisable le soir même d'ailleurs tu
pourras le mettre sur tes épaules enfin
pas toi mais celui qui le gagnera
une chance
est-ce que tu auras peut-être d'autres
roues d'ailleurs est-ce que tu feras des
dédicaces sur place bac ici des gens
t'apportent
un livre si vous
voulez une dédicace vous pouvez toujours
commander chez moi mais ils peuvent
commander chez toi et te demander après
la dictée casse en réel bah ouais oui
vous pouvez demander la dédicace en réel
mais n'hésitez pas à demander vos
dédicaces sur Alpha échec
mais en réel aussi il y a pas de souci
en réel faut quand même avoir le courage
après
si on te tend un stylo on sait pas trop
où il va finir
en utiliser que pour signer important de
signaler quand même ça pourrait faire
mal
si sur un ticket
en train d'être écrit mais bon il y a
les
ça va sortir qu'en janvier dans ton
livre retardenne
il y a le progresser aux échecs mais
surtout gagner aux échecs parce que
c'est le plus important
et on me demande si la zone à l'étage
est entrée libre pour les spectateurs
alors ce sera entre libre mais tu
pourras pas rentrer là où le tournoi
jouera ni dans l'arène et c'est vraiment
ça qui est exceptionnel sur ce tournoi
ce sera ce sera la reine ce sera une
première mondiale c'est jamais arrivé
dans le monde des échecs vous pouvez
participer à ça il y aura Maxime ouais
normalement j'ai l'impression il fait
une erreur là il mange un fruit de la
passion ah mais il a un kaki quand même
il a l'air déçu du fruit de la passion
quand même
attention est-ce que c'est pas une
erreur de pas de pas manger le kaki
c'est une erreur j'ai acheté des kakis
là qui était pas terrible les derniers
j'en ai eu des très très bons là
quelques fois et là ça a un peu baissé
c'est dur il faut qu'il soit bon les
kaki donc c'est
d'ailleurs il y a des
il y a des gens qui s'arrêtent au
premier kaki goûter en fait que si tu
sais pas le choisir tu prends un kaki au
hasard bah c'est souvent pas terrible
quand tu es au hasard parce que c'est
ça devrait être interdit après c'est
moins risqué parce que tu peux pas avoir
de trop mauvais kaki pomme c'est
toujours pareil
ça ils en vendent pas trop en France du
kaki séché
non même moi je le connais pas c'est
très très bon ça
Léo Redouane qui est pas bien qui nous
met pas bien là qu'il a deux plaques
miniers chez lui on n'est pas bien
moi je l'ai toujours pas quoi
c'est elle qui doit kiffer tout ici
pourquoi pourquoi elle m'a pas mis
encore mon plaque minier on aurait été
très bien là Kevin
si je viens je ramène mes kakis
je sais pas combien de temps il faut
pour avoir des
plaques déjà un peu un peu grand quoi
est-ce que si je plante si je plante à
Noël je peux avoir pour l'an prochain ça
dépend d'une graine non mais si tu
prends un je sais pas si ça s'appelle un
plan comment ça s'appelle mais c'est sûr
que oui ça dépend parce que des fois tu
as des par exemple les citronniers je
suis pas sûr que tu as la même ah si moi
j'ai acheté c'est instant
si vous avez des conseils n'hésitez pas
on en a besoin je prends
les conseils kakis
ça reprend quand Ben tout le monde a
envie que ça reprenne les joueurs mais
bon il y a la page de pub à mon avis
portant quand même les pubs
mais bon aujourd'hui c'est spécialement
pour pour vendre les places à Lake up en
fait c'est pour laisser le temps aux
gens d'acheter les billets
on le sait
Kevin a raison c'est un nom si tu le
prends assez avancer ah bah jardinier
avant tout Martinique 10 allez ça repart
Baki et ça repart en blanc
alors attends
en fait il a il a vraiment décidé de
c'est trop son choix d'ouverture encore
et Maxime qui repartent pas dans la
finale bizarrement elle s'était bien
passée
mais il repart je pense que toutes ces
berlinoises se sont bien placées à
Maxime à part peut-être la deuxième mais
bon c'est trois sur quatre ou quatre sur
cinq davantage donc il va il va changer
que en queue en belette en réalité
d'ouverture probablement
joueur de belette avant tout
ok probablement
en fait tu sais plus avant tu savais
Vaki qui est pas bien il a plus les
infos ouais ouais je sais pas
en fait pour Yann mais c'est Patrick
Bruel oui en fait on a toujours su il
bosse pour le Championnat du Monde en
fait Patrick de retour il s'est toujours
tout
ah mais c'est du coup je comprends
maintenant pourquoi tu dis que c'est
chouette berlinois sont bizarres bah qui
j'espère mon livre de pas sortir encore
[Rires]
ça donne quoi cette position avec le
pion en dessin
en général ça va pour les Noirs mais il
faut quand même mettre c'est assez
désagréable
d'ailleurs là il donne le fou il a
craqué tout de suite normalement il faut
jouer des 6 mais
ouais bah c'est encore ce qui se passe
mal pour Yann des 6 là j'imagine
elle se passe toute ma vie je sais pas
pourquoi il joue pourquoi il joue
ça peut être une bonne info pour Ding
d'essayer un E4 peut-être
après on sait pas six jours à ça ou
peut-être plus tôt il jouera la pétrole
comme même pour l'entraînement tu vois
je sais pas je comprends pas en fait
j'ai pas de il pourrait faire que des
pétroles en réalité non
quitte
des choses qu'il a pas envie de montrer
donc ça je comprends mais pourquoi tu
joues pas une nage d'or pour
même jouer avec Manoff
la française contre Maxime on peut
comprendre c'était pas très bien passé
la dernière fois
après non alors là on nous dit que la
structure elle est moche pour les blancs
non mais elle est pas si moche parce que
tu auras au pire bah il y a un pion
isolé chez les noirs et tu auras
toujours du C4 par contre il faut pas il
faut pas échanger les fous de casse
blanche pour les blancs là ça serait un
rêve pour pour rien mais ça n'arrivera
pas
qu'est-ce qu'il est beau ce fout en
Détroit là qui va arriver ou en G2
ouais et surtout ça ça fait blairer les
cales la casses C4 ou d'autres cases
avec les fous de casse blanche ok c'est
pas assez petit
pas mal joué l'accueil j'ai cinq fois
cinq quand même pour taper ces deux
il va peut-être finalement changer les
fous de casse blond sur les fous des
trois maintenant
faut prendre des trois cépendrais trop
mais au moins ils récupèrent la
structure non il joue ces quatre ouais
deux trois coups bizarres de chez Maxime
mais Maxime qui a réussi à jouer plus
vite là en 3 + 1 alors que c'était Niane
qui jouait plus vite dans les parties
précédentes T4 aussi
il fait des coups à côté quoi
complètement à côté
et ça a toujours été un de ses défauts
finalement alors après il a quand même
bien gommé dans les tournois très
importants comme les candidats mon match
championnat du monde il avait fini par
craquer
mais il a réussi à les gommer mais ça
revient quand même
ponctuellement il fait quelques très bon
coup mais des fois
ça paraît évident que Maxime il est
Maxime un peu plus fort ce soir mais
après ça peut tellement se voir à rien
Maxime
le dominer
en fait
de manière très directe je crois qu'ils
ont le même âge non Maxime et dépôt
comme
Carya Kim
et oui
l'année en or
90 ouais ça clique fort
et intéressant d'ailleurs de voir vu que
tu parles de Magnus et de Néo est-ce que
Magnus va tenter d'aller rechercher son
titre mondial
après après le match sur le prochain
cycle ou pas
pourquoi je sais pas pourquoi en fait
non mais c'est une question que je me
posais l'autre l'autre nuit
de reprendre son titre ou de repasser
par les candidats là
Maxime parce que les cases blanches
quand même et le fou B6 qui peut se
retrouver hors jeu
vite vite taper sur toutes les cases
blanches montées noires et alors on n'a
pas l'habitude ici nous on connaît bien
les cases noires mais là les cases
blanches ça fait un petit peu peur
il faut le fou qui est très très loin de
du jeu qui a été 4 il laisse pas trop
pour à cette tempo
là parce que
surprend tout reprend et cavaliers 7
échec
allez ça va le faire pour Maxime
bah ça a été vu par Yann
moi j'avais en fait oui bon oui mais moi
j'avais même moi j'avais oui c'est bon
en fait ça joue pas si bien désolé on
vous a trompé sur un marchandise
inhabituelles quand même
oh bah ça c'était quand même pas très
dur pour que j'ai c'est que c'était pas
très dur
il mériterait que je lui envoie un petit
un petit power tactique il y a là je
pense c'est gagneuse
oui bon là parce que là il a du lire
aux échecs en fait
il a sacrifié une pièce c'est en fait ce
qu'on demande nul ou ouais ça a été un
peu vite cette fin de partie en fait
Yann il a sacrifié une pièce pour
essayer de mater mais il y avait juste
deux trois petits échecs pour échanger
les dames chez Maxime il s'est retrouvé
qu'une pièce en plus qui a eu abandon
évidemment voilà je prends F6
attention à Maxime il faut pas là il
peut l'enfoncer il y a plus de pour
Maxime
mais là la structure elle est un peu
bizarre non il va jouer C4 attention il
est joue bien ces lignes il y a
va lui jouer ces quatre B4 un peu comme
dans la partie plus simple mais Maxime
qui avait réussi à défendre un
héroïquement
F5 F3 j'imagine web 4 tu peux pas faire
fou F3 provoquer
je disais de la merde
[Musique]
et on a vu que les positions techniques
ils les jouent bien n'est pas
peut-être ce qu'il faut éviter il est en
train de manger une pomme je crois
maximum
ou peut-être un cas qui pomme
je crois que c'est une pomme là
le kakistan pousse ses pieds c'est
peut-être un cas qui pomme je sais pas
qui pomme dans le chat moi j'ai pas bien
vu ça peut être un cas qui pomme
ok pas mal de mettre le fond en C6
plutôt qu'en E6 mais il peut quand même
se prendre du B4 B5
sur la jouer pour les Noirs les pions
vont être fixes un peu bizarre quand
même parce que tu ouvres le fou c'est 6
je vais je voyais plutôt du F3
[Musique]
d'être sûr que c'est un cas qui pomme là
qui est mangé
je suis pas si sûr
j'ai l'impression que c'est une pomme
moi mais bon
en fait c'est peut-être juste autre
chose
ok il t'a pas 5 quand même avec ce tour
reprend le 5
il va descendre ça non encore
mais c'est pas mal ce qu'il fait là
depuis quelques coups
[Musique]
c'est vrai que il est sur quasiment il
peut être faible un certain moment donné
de la partie
j'arrive pas il veut tout reprendre ses
prends
[Musique]
j'ai pas la rêve des coups yanèse
à la maxime qui domine maintenant ce
match ça se voit il a pris un début de
match difficile maxime a réussi à très
très bien défendre là sur sur deux trois
parties et il a réussi petit à petit à
faire dégoupiller Yann et à prendre le
dessus
et en plus si c'est quand même pris
cette enfermement de tour à un moment là
de du match
il a pas de choc après ça
s'il a perdu sa tour en F6 là dans la
berlinoise mais ouais il a pris la
mesure de Yann et il est un peu un peu
plus fort pour le moment sur ce match
après c'est un joueur qui lui a souvent
bien réussi
on se rappelle un de cette partie
extraordinaire qui est dans le livre
d'ailleurs progresser aux échecs parti
extraordinaire de Maxime phase retour
des candidats phase allée des candidats
pardon la septième et ultime partie
avant le
lajournement du tournoi Maxime qui
n'avait emporté dans une française
c'est une des meilleures parties de sa
vie non juste
partie extraordinaire de Maxime
et là il est encore en train de
dégoupiller Yann
c'est en train de bien se passer là
parce qu'il y a pas le tour des sisters
c'est en train de
de cette partie elle peut vraiment nous
faire passer dans le verre qui
ça peut être fin du match là
on peut en faut trois échec il est
encore redonner tour des cinq tours
français 5
je pense qu'il a loupé mais il avait pas
le choix tu me diras
ça ressemble à presque gagné
une balle de match au blanc
après attention aux belettes quand même
il faut toujours se méfier
la concentration parce qu'on peut l'être
après ça va vite mais bon il aura le
match en main il pourra gérer le match
roi F1 c'est forcé
mais il va dépasser Yann
[Musique]
G7 encore
la tension à 3 ici
Maxime qui trouve pas le lien qui prend
la nul
c'est pas mal Maxime qui reprend les
pièces blanches
et là il y a une partie vraiment
importante
c'est trop encore une
bon bah ça va pas mieux se passer bah
quitte la berlinoise ça
oh bah oui là ça va là ça va faire très
mal Maxime qui fait les cars qui fait la
course en tête dans ce match il nous a
fait peur dans la première partie Yann
qui avait sorti une super finale et
depuis Maxime qui défend tout qui
renvoie toutes les balles
est-ce que Maxime il va pas jouer l'arme
de dépôt B4 vous prend à deux cavalier
prend à deux noms et je te reprends
pas de nul évidemment
et on dit la deuxième partie ouais la
deuxième partie c'est vrai que la
deuxième a été décisive en fait c'est
vrai quand on repense Maxime là c'est 2
3e 4e partie la quand il a défendu et
qu'il a réussi après à retourner en
victoire c'est vrai que c'est
c'était un moment charnière de ce match
et là 5 je crois que c'est pas un très
bon coup ici à 5
h
allez c'est d'avoir du décatres là un
peu ici j'ai envie de jouer ces quatre
comme ça à ma première vue après je sais
pas si si ça passe ici
par principe
complètement au hasard c'est quoi trop
ici ah mais c'est les plus beaux
avancer ce qu'on peut jouer sur A5
[Musique]
tour B8
mais là il y a moins de C4 maintenant
moins explosif
il y a plus de 4 mais bon c'est pas
vite
il s'est remis à clic très vite il veut
jouer quoi sur
[Musique]
il a peut-être dû à 4 non à 4 B1 pour
jouer sur la surcharge du cavalier là la
tour qui ouais mais non
tu retouches la dame ouais
un peu bizarre mais bon
[Musique]
après je suis pas hyper fan du parce que
ça met la dame sur la tour mais bon il
veut tout rein quand même mettre une
pression
il faut bien cliquer donc c'est
peut-être pas mal
on les connaît pas ces cases en fait
il nous faut l'antimaser le spécialiste
des cases blanches
c'est ça qui laisse C4 ici
4 et puis on passera peut-être ouais
et bien vu Baki c'est ça donne avantage
blanc C4
ça donne nette avantage c'est 0,7
mais là il n'y a pas P4
j'avais pas et là sur F5 tu vas t'ouvrir
la diagonale de la dame donc tu vas
avoir un problème
ouais mais ici
qui a remis un coup de collier un niveau
temps
ouais même niveau cours
son cavalier B7 là il fait il fait des
très jolis coups des coups qui font mal
en fait devant l'échiquier il y a pas
qui a laissé trois juste là
c'était une partie Maxime pouvait
s'envoler et là c'est Yann qui est en
train de alors pas complètement recoller
Maxime qui va encore avoir un point
d'avance
si la paire mais Yann qui recolle un peu
quand même là
[Musique]
au niveau des coûts il sait il sait
nettement
il fait mal sur cette partie
3 d'un point 3 qui tue c'est E4 je lis
je le dis parce qu'il est beau si on
prend dame prend et tu vas réussir à
rentrer j'imagine
français donc
pas le temps pour la fourchette dans le
cèdre
attention il fait il joue avec le feu
quand même Yann c'est un roi je dame F4
on peut échanger on le gagnant F8 oh là
ça devrait passer quand même parce que
Yann il prend trop de risques
inconsidérés
là il s'en sort enfin ils s'en sort
c'est même pas encore complètement fini
à toi aussi ce bien joué contre le
cavalier F5 c'est Vlad qui nous avait
appris ça
mais l'ordi donner ce que tu as dit
ouais
c'était juste pour prendre le pion
oui c'est vrai que c'est con mais c'est
efficace ouais
et là ça va être du H Synco donc qui va
partir pour ouvrir le roi
ça ça gagne tranquille pour les noirs
pas très dur ça non à gagner
je pense pas mais bon on sait jamais tu
as toujours des petites forteresses qui
peuvent se créer regarde la roi F6 ça
devient seul coup déjà non mais c'est
sûr qu'il faut la jouer mais c'était
juste une question
ouais il y a des fourchettes aussi on
peut se prendre des mais là c'est tout
F3 et le roi à quoi que le roi F4
tu vois pas si facile il va devoir jouer
F5 F5 et 4
ok mais c'est déjà calcule c'est déjà
faut pas oublier que la tour B3 est en
l'air
cavalier
mais bon est-ce que c'est très facile
bah cette partie non c'est pas facile
même là encore
c'est compliqué à les échecs
je crois que c'est toujours gagnant mais
l'ordi donne -50 mais
déjà une case au dessus c'est nul ouais
c'est pas facile
ouais
c'est le problème quand vous avez cette
disposition de pions c'est que les
finales depuis elles sont perdants
on n'a pas le temps d'expliquer pour toi
mais une Range aussi vous allez voir
vous pouvez aller voir la Master Class
sur les finales roi pion en fait
peut-être quelqu'un va mettre le lien et
c'est tout expliqué mais là il y a pas
le temps et ça repart dans une nage
d'orphé Yann qui recolle qui reste dans
le match 5 et demi si c'est demi
Maxime qui a raison contre Yann parce
que les 4 5 il souffre quand même il y
avait pas une tourelle qui pouvait
partir en C3 là pour prendre 4 et jouer
cale de moins mais activités
mais attention quand même c'était pas
suffisant il y avait peut-être du foie
F3
maximesque quand même les tours c3-1 et
puis là attention cavaliers des 5 ça
peut partir à tout moment
heureusement il y a fou crampions
français de Tours c'est un tour C8 ok ça
a l'air d'aller là
quel complexe pour
océen et là il va penser au sacrifice en
C3 Maxime de plus en plus
il va partir
le sacrifice et surtout faut éviter
qu'il y ait des cinq quoi que tout FC 8
ça évite encore j'ai l'impression je
fous ces quatre j'aime pas trop échanger
ce fou mais bon
sans cette
à être un bon fou
un deux tours
on les connaît pas les cases blanches on
a beaucoup d'avantages en France mais
les cases blanches c'est pas notre fort
songback qui est pas très heureux de ce
sacrifice je connais Baki fait après
tu fais ta petite
une belle case en Détroit il va plutôt
aller en F4
tu fais ta petite voix mécontent à qui
là
je te connais je te connais Baki
je pense que les compensations elles
sont juste pas suffisantes
après Maxime un orfèvre un joyeux
si Maxime était une monde dans cette
position ce serait une Philippe Patek
qui
c'était une voiture ce serait une fée
toujours su
mais tu vois même si il récupère des
pions
les cases blanches
allez menaces
il a un coup pas facile à jouer je pense
là
il revient dans la partie là
il n'avait jamais quitté
ouais je pense qu'il était vraiment
moins bien mais là cavalier de Fougères
fui qui met une belle pression
a pas de pas de super casse
bien aussi d'imprompre B7
Maxime il peut avoir des chances mais en
direct
non mais ils sont beaucoup trop fort en
fait ouais mais ils ont ils ont vu qu'un
celles
ouais mais le voir c'est une chose mais
régler le problème aussi élégamment et
rapidement c'est incroyable
c'est enfin c'est pas le même niveau bah
qui
est
niveau de jeu stratosphérique
un niveau de jeu final de Beckham
ça quand même un peu au-dessus la backup
acquis j'ai peur
tu imagines la bécable t'imagines tu
mets les deux mêmes personnes avec le
public et tout c'est une dinguerie
qui prend 5 l'ordi donne
c'est fou eux trois bon bah c'est pour
ça qu'il va gagner le match maximum
[Musique]
là j'ai les coups là quand c'est des
trucs à la con comme ça je suis très
heureux comme frangin
l'ordi donne tour bb1 plus ou moins seul
coup de défense
ça va être joué mais
contre coeur
c'est trop fort
il doit être déçu un épaule d'être venu
à ce match c'est trop au dessus
qu'est-ce qu'il est fort Maxime mais
c'est pour ça tu vois ça qui file la
qualité c'est pas très bon et tout mais
le problème c'est que il domine dans ce
petit jeu
elle a [ __ ] en géant il a quand même
pas de bol n'est pas parce qu'il aurait
pu avoir un truc qui défend
bye
non mais c'est trop que ça marche
partout là
il va pas être bien là
je sais pas s'il y a pas un peu de
parade dans l'équipe de dépôt
[Musique]
il est pas bien là c'est terrible
quasiment
désolé désolé
ça fait 7,5 importantes ça là parce que
ne pourraient pu recoller et là Maxime
il peut faire les là c'est la pause
après cette partie c'est vrai bah qui ça
te manquait à l'épaule non
bah ouais on en a besoin hein c'est
juste avant la pause
est-ce qu'on peut avoir la cam dans son
match contre
quand Magnus ma couleur inversée
il choisit des je trouve qu'avec les
Noirs ils choisissent des lignes
terribles
ouais après c'est pas facile quand tu
quand tu te ta table autant sur le match
championnat du monde qui arrive et que
tu dois jouer un match sans jouer tes
ouvertures ça doit pas être simple
ouais
en plus mais bon
c'est sûr j'essaye de lui trouver des
excuses bah qui
et la deuxième câble dont je peux pas
vous la montrer mais je la vois
bah il a pas l'air bien non plus sur la
deuxième c'est à peu près pareil
mais il semble avoir fait un régime par
contre clairement
il doit être motivé comme jamais pour
devenir champion du monde Yann
ou est-ce que c'est pour devenir
champion du monde c'est pas sûr c'est
peut-être comment elle s'appelle ce
n'est jamais
qui pêche
oui on sait très bien de quoi ça parle
ouais et surtout toi Baki tu es aussi en
régime on sait de quoi ça parle allez en
fait tu es pushiades aussi quoi oui on a
compris bah qui
c'est pas pour être 2007 ou champion du
monde
si jamais n'hésite pas dans un live à
venir avec des petits papiers à nous
montrer si ça se passe vraiment mal à la
maison on sera là-bas qui pour toi on te
prend quel que soit ton poids ici
ah mais ouais c'est sûr que les patrons
ça peut
en fait tu as raison c'est oui enfin
c'est match de championnat du monde il y
en a absolument rien à [ __ ] en fait
bon il fait des prépas pour le match de
championnat du monde pas du régime quel
est le principe
dans des cartes
ça y est ça explose
ça explose
on a toujours su depuis le début
on a commencé à savoir les trois
premières parties j'étais pas serein
quand même hein
petit à petit Maxime qui a pris sa
mesure et là là le choc dans la
précédente 2 minutes 36 et avoir cette
poubelle c'est dur quoi
il continue à s'alimenter j'ai
l'impression qu'il mange
des amandes ou des ou des fruits secs là
il y a
continue quand même à essayer de rester
dedans
donc le vainqueur de ce match jouera le
vainqueur du match entre sceaux et Abdou
ça torov je crois
ça peut être du Abdou d'ailleurs
celui qui va gagner ce match il sera
favori sur le prochain probablement
oui mais ce sera pas gagné d'avance
Abdou qui peut être un joueur gênant
pour Maxime d'ailleurs peut-être plus
que ça bizarrement
de parler style non ou c'est moi qui
raconte de la merde
tu sais pas tu as pas les rêves quoi
il t'inspire pas grand chose à
je l'ai battu les deux dernières fois
non
en fait
c'est peut-être le seul que je donne
oui oui mais bon il va être gênant
oui c'est juste que tu envoies des punch
en fait à tout bout de champ maintenant
on a un bacilla chez
ben non mais bon c'est vrai quoi
ce qui fait peur
oui c'est vrai j'avais oublié oui en
fait l'autre non plus ne fait pas peur
en fait sur le prochain match en fait
oui en fait
ok ça dépend après c'est fou il fait
n'importe quoi et puis tout d'un coup il
défend comme un c'est pas sûr qu'il a
gagné le maximum
ça qui est incroyable dans ce match
ouais c'est quand tu fais un coup pareil
que tu laisses cavalier pour H6 que
normalement tu mentalement en fait bon
là et puis là il fait dame 5 tours
[Musique]
c'était trop gagnant pour que ce soit
difficile
ouais ok mais quand même on s'accroche
il s'accroche quand même un petit peu
il va bientôt falloir lâcher là ça
s'appelle de Punto ça joli
là ça commence à sentir bon mais là il y
a pas assez la pause normalement
cheesecom qui oublie les peaux non ah
bah oui petite pause bah qui elle fait
du bien celle-là
non je suis obligé mais c'était dur sans
cette pause là j'étais pas bien je me
disais ça va jouer pendant une heure
d'affilée on n'avait pas le rythme à qui
là il reste 24 minutes de jeu seulement
derrière on va pouvoir resoufler
rapidement
et c'est du 1 0 en plus maintenant non
c'est encore trois plus simples là c'est
la pause des trois plus simples qui
attention
c'est beau ah bah ouais c'est je savais
que celle-là elle te ferait
particulièrement plaisir la petite pause
au milieu des trois plus simples
le petit 10 minutes là qui permet de je
sais pas si c'est pas un peu moins c'est
peut-être 6 minutes ici
il a compris
il mange dehors
mais après c'est peut-être mieux pour
Maxime encore il va augmenter la vente
c'est quasiment sûr
je pense que la pose ça va plus
s'énerver qu'autre chose il y a en
réalité
ça va plus s'énerver qu'autre chose
alors est-ce que c'est place elles
partent pour le tournoi du 10 est-ce
qu'il en reste encore beaucoup je vais
te dire ça je sais comment comment
savoir
ce qui reste encore beaucoup de place
spectateurs
parce que les gens ont commencé à en
prendre
on va savoir
il en reste encore une trentaine qui
déplace spectateurs
et dans ton tournoi tu veux que je
puisse combien il en reste dans ton
tournoi
dans mon tournoi est-ce qu'il est resté
est-ce que j'ai déjà perdu le mag ou pas
je crois qu'il en reste plus en fait
j'arrive pas à savoir mes dernières
articles en stock et j'arrive pas à ça
je sais pas combien il en reste dans ton
tournoi quasiment pas
ce que vous avez déjà perdu le mug en
fait ou quelqu'un l'a gagné
il en reste déjà presque plus et dans la
poule de ma zone
il est pas il fait pas une roue du mug
ou du ou du drapeau
mais j'arrive pas à savoir parce que
écrit presque plus de place dans le toit
mais je peux pas vivre un dernière place
donc peut-être que je sais pas je peux
pas dire
tournoi de maso il reste encore une
vingtaine de places et toi je sais pas
et toi je sais pas j'ai acheté toutes
les places en me qualifier
en fait j'espère qu'il y a pas quelqu'un
qui a pris
j'imagine qu'il en reste moins d'une
dizaine
si vous êtes sur Paris bien sûr ça va
être une journée exceptionnelle
mais surtout
sur tous les plats spectateurs là qui
partent pas assez vite
c'est ça le difficulté qui c'est
tellement dommage il y a beaucoup de
gens qui prennent des places joueurs de
pas de pas prendre les places
spectateurs
il va y avoir des beaux matchs dans
cette arène
ok oui
il y aura de
il va y avoir des beaux matchs dans cet
arène tu vas peut-être devoir jouer un
match contre Cornetto ça va être
complexe les ouvertures
c'est sûr qu'il est en train de se
préparer depuis une semaine
il est allé en Irlande pour se préparer
est-ce que est-ce que les bijoux dans ma
poule
[Musique]
je pense j'ai du stunt du marc de café
tu as peut-être du Libye aussi
du skyblos exact ce qui peut te mettre
très mal
[Musique]
à l'époque il y a pas la chose
petit à petit
ça a commencé ou pas non non
la poule de Mazo mon avis il est plus
favori que ma zone malheureusement
pour Seb
t'assure tout marlou l'enchanteur ah oui
t'as marlou l'enchanteur aussi
60 joueurs
9 parties tu as quand même pas mal de
chance de tomber ouais
ça commence à gagner un petit peu au
début tu as deux sur deux tu as quoi 10
50 % de change au pire après après je
reste pendant le deuxième groupe
dans le public non dans le deuxième
groupe
salon
dangereux backy
35 qui t'avait qui t'avait mis un peu en
danger je me rappelle dans une baie
Arena
et alors est-ce que si on se fait
éliminer on peut avoir une place
spectateur après ou pas ça dépend si il
en reste ou pas
mais c'est terrible ça veut dire que je
dois prendre une place spectateur pour
moi si je perds ça va tu vas pas perdre
bah qui mais théoriquement ouais
ça dépend et tu as la pause qui continue
là il est
le temps pour prendre pour prendre les
places
il y a qu'à pas perdre
ils pourront prendre un ou deux de plus
pour être bien sûr avant les une 0 à 5
qui te dit oui de toute façon je te
passe la mienne je vais me qualifier
[Rires]
pourquoi pas ça va être
mais bon n'ayez pas peur de venir jouer
quel est le plus petit élo des joueurs
ça je sais pas encore
ouais mais j'ai pas forcément moi qui
m'occupe de tout bah qui te cache pas
donc
c'est déjà beaucoup c'est déjà beaucoup
et ça part Yann qui joue à une anglaise
qui change
pour jouer contre des 500
[Rires]
moi ça me va qui est le problème c'est
qu'il va peut-être faire exprès de
perdre les premières game en fait
pour être à zéro sur 4 quoi
bon alors cette c'est ça ressemble
maintenant à des genres de gambidables
où tu as réussi à faire ces cinq
ça clique complètement au hasard mais ce
qui peut pas prendre le pion dans C'est
un peu risqué ici de prendre le pion
chez Maxime il va jouer ouais
il laisse pas de dessin
ça peut permettre à Maxime de jouer faux
et 7 ici et d'être attend et pour ok
attention c'est pause ça peut ça peut
faire mal il faut se remettre dans le
bain tout de suite les pots qui étaient
plutôt en Suisse petit rocks 3 quand
même dans ce genre de position tu peux
avoir
en 3 minutes on va dire
et peut-être à 4 non inscrit la
compétition va compter pour le vélo
classement Blitz non pas du tout ça
comptera pas pour le classement feed
dans le cas très bizarre mais qui a été
8 un joli coup oui j'ai plus les du coup
j'ai plus les cames quand je vais me
remettre ça va là pour Maxime ah il a
pas petit rock malheureusement
tu as pas cavaliers
non c'est pas si facile je pensais qu'il
en était sorti là
alors dis vraiment fort alors dis je
dame G6 tour F5 cavaliers C6
c'est dur
très dur
mais c'est trouvé mais c'était dur
c'est un joli coup dame
B7 à cause de tout reprendre des
vitesses
comment tu défends
[Musique]
mais là c'est bien pour les Noirs quand
même
il va rester avec son fou c'est tout
pendant un moment
[Musique]
qui a raison il est tellement dominant
avec les Blancs il mène dans le match
j'ai oublié de relancer le chronomètre
il est très tranquille
il répète il y a une qui veut pas
répéter il doit se sentir obligé
du coup il laisse
les pièces de des blancs sont quand même
placées bizarres non
je sais pas si le petit rock c'est le
meilleur coup je pense qu'ils pouvaient
réfléchir à G6 en fait et là
là c'est placé bizarrement mais c'est
quand même vers le roi tu vois qu'il y a
aussi il peut jouer ouais ça ou même foi
ou même trois ça tourne elle est utile
quand même
ça tourne un petit peu je trouve
[Musique]
Maxime il est quand même assez heureux
sur les coups comme Dame des deux ou la
dame 8
il a eu un petit peu de réussite à
certains moments importants après la
réussite sourit aux audacieux il en faut
toujours un petit peu de toute façon les
matchs sont tellement serrés
puis elle est méritée aussi
donc c'est pas trop de réussite
non non mais c'est bien
c'est un petit peu heureux mais bon
c'est aussi Yann qui est pas hyper
précis dans ces calculs on le voit
depuis le début du match
Maxime qui a un tout petit peu au dessus
hein c'est pas énorme mais ça suffit à
faire les cartes pour le moment
cette pause qui a fait du bien quand
même à Yann
ouais
qui reviennent un peu là à deux ou deux
points avant les bullets ce serait bien
de le laisser à - 3
c'est quand même un écart confortable
qui est max problème avec son roi Maxime
pas facile à jouer mais il a réussi à
jouer vite quand même à bien défendre
quand il a peu de temps Maxime on le
sent très affûté
aujourd'hui
si c'est bien joué il se replace
attention quand même un les cases noires
ça s'approche du roi là-bas qui
est en train d'arriver en F6
Maxime qui a plus de temps plus de 20
secondes
tu reprends des 5D en plus c'est foot et
non ça marche pas j'ai peur que ça qu'on
s'incline ici
Yann qui réussit à s'accrocher à nos
basques
voilà il a lâché ce 5 finalement même
c'est peut-être pas une bonne nouvelle
pour nous bah qui
se passait très bien dans les ouvertures
et
ces méthodes
ça sort les ouvertures interdites côté
Yann
c'est trop
heureusement peut-être que l'arbitrage
de peut-être c'est les arbitres comme un
qui sont intervenus on l'a vu réfléchir
un petit peu il a pas fait la ruse
mais bon c'est moins agréable à jouer
que
c'est plus compliqué que toutes les
berlinoises c'est plus trois résultats
on sent qu'il peut faire plus peur là
dessus il y en aurait
bizarre son choix de cette empalé là sur
cette berlinée je te dis la il s'est
fait un délire c'est peut-être pas trop
laide en fait
il est peut-être pas trop net de partout
et Maxime
là comme c'est C4 B4 A4 la 5 B5 C5 ça
fait mal
et il y a un problème sur E5 le cavalier
G3 est tellement mal placé
c'est ce que j'ai un truc qui allait pas
dans la position et je le trouve comment
il s'est remis dans le match c'est
incroyable la pause
regarde son tour des cinq Tour Eiffel
c'était bizarre aussi
non c'est aussi la réussite
c'est un peu tourner tout ça
tape 5 et 4
attention comment trouver du jeu là
F4 bien joué là j'aime bien ce genre de
coups
en fait c'est juste qu'il avait un
problème de batterie dans le plugin
si c'est parmi dans le match en fait il
a remis le plug
désolé j'étais obligé
nous dit qu'il a pris sa place
spectateur là sa facture et ben écoute
on t'attendra de pied ferme mais là
ouais j'ai 5 c'est bien joué aussi et là
il enchaîne les très très bon coup Yann
il peut retrouver
de la
apparemment non mais ouais
[Musique]
il y a un truc qui va pas là quand même
on sent que après tu auras assez vite
là 5
ouf
ça remet complètement Maxime dans le
truc c'était moins de 80 c'est moins 0,6
ça a été loupé chez Yann j'ai pas vu
le bazar dans cette partie ouais mais
Maxime peut même la gagner hein
ou quelque chose comme ça
c'est sûr que ça allait être comme ça
faut prendre des huit heures prend des 8
et là peut-être un tour à D1
qui part peut-être je sais pas c'est dur
à dire ah là c'est un truc c'est que le
fou c'est ici et le fou c'est ici c'est
tout ah c'est pas mal tour des deux il y
a pas
menace tour des deux
positions là où il est bien au dessus
Diane dans ce match
il est très fort dans ce genre de
position Maxime par rapport à Yann ce
soir
il fait un gros match Maxime
[Musique]
aussi le coup en fait c'était pas faux
assister cavaliers G6 pour revenir sur
le Pione 5 et maintenant en fait le
fouet décalé il y a plus d'harmonie donc
il va faire que j'ai 6 mais
bon ça reste un peu mieux pour les Noirs
quand même
pas terrible
parce que là
il va faire tout rate
j'ai deux faut prendre des trois combien
de fois il nous a fait ça dans le match
c'était facile en plus que c'était sa
menace c'est fou B5 c'était clairement
pour
il était revenu mais bon il est reparti
il est reparti
il réussit pas à rester concentré
[Musique]
qui est plus que trouvable en plus
c'est pour ça que Maxime va gagner ce
match plus consistant
qui va partir quand même
à 6 non
[Musique]
après j'ai pas tous les coups
ça va trop vite pour moi
attention Maxime attention ouais il est
chaud en réalité
il est revenu il est revenu mais bon
cavaliers G4 non
il y a pas fou français
il y a pas il y a mais ça c'est nul
juste non
les deux s'en sortent bien
et puis ça finit on s'est même ah ben je
sais pas si vous arrivez à suivre mais
même nous on a du mal à avoir un roi des
7 fous des 6 ou un truc comme ça qui
gagnait pour les Noirs ça s'est joué
juste
allez c'est bien Maxime qui qui par
rapport au scénario de la partie
évidemment on aurait gagné mais prendre
la nul c'est quand même pas si mal il
fait trop d'erreur dans cette partie là
et tu vas voir en belette ça sera encore
ça sera encore pire je pense
je pense aussi
le plug qu'il a lâché on nous dit dans
le dans le chat la batterie russe qui
tient moins bien que la batterie
française
ah bah ça se joue à ça aussi les matchs
ça joue au pile en fait
du race
tu vois là ça va être le genre de
position ou Yann il va on va voir ce que
ça va donner mais
je suis d'accord avec toi
je trouve qu'il a très bien joué ces
trucs plus ou moins égal là
avec des toutes petites pressions il a
pu jouer pendant très longtemps très
bien et c'est là dessus qu'il a fait des
progrès
non ça a l'air d'aller
Maxime qui prend son temps au bon moment
mais qui joue pas forcément le meilleur
cours pas grand tempo
c'est là où il est il est plus fort ce
soir mais mais quand c'est pas clair il
fera il fera la plus grosse erreur
mais Vlad il m'a dit que c'est un truc
sur lesquels beaucoup de gens sous-est
enfin sous-estimés Yann que beaucoup
d'observateurs pas comme toi mais on va
dire un peu un peu plus lointain les
échecs mais ils ont pas compris que Yann
son point fort c'était les positions
plus égales très léger
là
sur ce côté-là regarde ok il a pas juste
pris un avantage avec ce grand rock là
magnifique ce genre
il faut prendre un pion en un coup
ouais mais bon il va gagner la finale
elle est j'ai pas en fait
bon ça c'est très fort tu vas faire roi
des droits des trois
oui il pouvait juste gagner un pion en
un coup quoi mais
ouais il est pas il est pas précis
d'ailleurs là il laisse du
temps
qui va pouvoir attaquer tous les pions
il va la tenir Maxime en fait
un roi d'ici c'est tout [ __ ]
ça c'est pour Maxime non mais ne dépôts
là mais il est en tilte quand même non à
jouer tempo comme ça ouais mais il
partait trop loin Maxime la tour à 5 à 5
mais bon tu auras 5 pour le 5 3
ça a l'air gagnant
maintenant il y a
je dis qu'il la tient Maxime et celle-là
pourquoi il a remis son rendez-vous
trouve pas
défendre Yann trop négligent
qui défend très précisément
ce serait bien de garder ce plus de
l'avant les avant les pelettes voir même
l'augmenter à la prochaine
même sur celle là il y a pas droit E5 et
des quatre
un des quatre des trois et tout aussi
pouvoir
F4 ouais
qui a pas fait le tour prend des seins
qui gagne juste un pion tout seul
c'est quand même étonnant comme faute
des fois c'est surprenant parce qu'il
joue tellement bien tout le temps et des
fois il rate c'est même pas raté en fait
c'est juste un pion en prison tu le
prends quoi
tu as l'impression qu'il réfléchit pas
des fois
c'est comment comment défendre
maintenant
on est proche quand même
des trois
ça a l'air bien là ce que fait Maxime
aussi
c'est très étonnant
[Musique]
il peut peut-être la sauver mais
eux sur roi D1
juste
je sais pas ou peut-être
dans les seuls coups qui perdaient
roi des trois rois
3D 4 3 c'est deux tours C8
pour ces 8 tours F4
ouais tu as raison en fait ça va Yann
qui fait trop de
trop négligent
au fait plus trois ouais mais incroyable
cette finale
voilà ça a bien tourné trop de gaffe
côté Yann
bien sûr mais contre Maxime tu peux pas
te permettre de laisser
c'est ça joue trop fort côté Maxime
puis la sacraque complètement c'est si
ça 5
là il a complètement de choc
il a complètement choquian allez il faut
pas le faut faire attention parce que il
a des fulgurances
il fait trop de fois de direct
aujourd'hui
et Maxime il est bien appliqué ouais
ouais c'est ça on sent qu'ils ont à peu
près le même niveau en soi
mais aujourd'hui il y a trop de trop
d'erreurs en un maxime lui qui en fait
quasiment pas
en tout cas qui en fait moins mais c'est
ça qui fait la différence par contre sur
ces pires que ça se passe pas super bien
mais on peut d'ailleurs on peut se
demander ce qui serait passé si dès le
début il jouait des pires coups le match
aurait pu être différent parce qu'on
sent que Maxime qui est complètement
dominant dans l'espagnol dans les pires
que il arrive moins à prendre la mesure
des positions il a plus de mal à les
jouer
c'est une pièce ça
c'est typiquement les erreurs qui peut
pas faire et qui peut le remettre
un petit peu remettre les pots dans le
match
qui en avait qui nous avait pas habitué
à ses erreurs là et qu'il a en fait une
très grosse c'est pour ça que la partie
d'avant elle était importante parce que
si Yann lavait gagné il prend le pion il
gagne celle-là c'est 9 9
ça se joue vraiment à rien quand même
ils sont ils sont proches dans le style
et dans le niveau de jeu
je sais pas si Maxime va la jouer très
longtemps celle là après il peut vouloir
faire tourner la pendule pour aller en
belette
il y a encore des chances
un peu automatiquement
là ça commence à devenir dur par contre
on prend le 5 ça va faire mal
ouais
[Musique]
après peut-être que Maxime
veut s'enlever une partie de trois plus
simples et elle est directement belette
ouais je pense que c'est ça là c'est
juste
et il reste combien de temps pour le 05
il lui reste 2 minutes donc il peut
juste attendre pour que jouer en 3 ans
c'est ça
peut relancer
ça peut un peu relancer le match
malheureusement
après comme tu disais en belette ça va
peut-être même être pire les gaffes de
Yann
je connais pas son niveau en belette
il doit avoir un niveau proche il donne
pas d'essai là
qui fait juste tourner
[Musique]
allez ça c'est bien joué quand même
la technique de conversion Diane c'est
quand même particulier
il fait juste pas attention après
attention parce qu'en une il peut
justement être plus focus
ça doit être la fin du temps
le petit bip
digne n'aurait pas laisser tourner
il a abandonné un truc on aurait jamais
abandonné en fait
il faut la gagner maintenant
ah ouais c'est bizarre ce qu'il fait
le plus simple d'après ordi c'est roi G7
mais bon c'est
à sa technique de gain c'est pas c'est
pas l'assurance touriste
ça va faire plus de mais ouais ça aurait
pu être quasi égalitaire quand on y
pense
dangereux
je vais récupérer quelque chose
[Musique]
je fais une petite pause vas-y vas-y
ça doit être la pause
[Musique]
allez deux points d'écart seulement
deux points d'écart simplement le match
qui est serré
allez c'est le dernier moment pour le
lien Ludwig pour acheter les places pour
la soirée du 10 du 10 décembre les plats
spectateurs pour venir sur le tournoi
vous avez dans le lien toutes les
explications qui jouera dans la reine je
peux je peux en profiter pour montrer la
reine attendez une seconde
ce que je vais y arriver
pendant qu'on a la petite pause
on en profite en profite du live et de
ses pauses à rallonge
pour faire notre petite pub
ouais ça va être dur quand même
ouais on voit pas très bien
on suit un peu pour voir quand même
ouais on suit complètement avec ce set
up mais ça ce sera la reine on peut
zoomer peut-être
on a du mal à zoomer quand même
allez joueur qui doit être fatigué ça
c'est sûr
j'ai une bonne photo si tu veux ouais
mais là j'aurais pas le temps de
l'afficher Ludwig mais la Reine des spot
Paris Première arrondissement
rue de Rivoli à côté du Louvre mesdames
et messieurs
si on a une place voir on n'a pas accès
à la finale en spectateur oh que non à
moins que tu te qualifies il faut
prendre les deux
la reine aussi grande que le
centre-ville de Limoges ce sera une
arène on pourra on pourra crier et
supporter les joueurs
Ludwig qui nous met
on va essayer
ah ben voilà Ludwig qui intervenu voilà
la reine avec le jeu de lumière les
siestes pour les joueurs et le public
qui sera derrière une centaine de
personnes ce sera le 10 décembre
Première Internationale Première Guerre
mondiale pour les échecs
tu joues mais tu peux pas avoir la
finale c'est pas la Coupe du monde non
plus
bah ouais je sais pas c'est comme dans
n'importe quoi que tu fais en fait c'est
pas parce que tu joues que tu as des
places
ce sera dans ce beau décor ça ce sera
pour pour les finales et ce que vous
avez vu avant c'était aussi pour la
phase de qualification donc de tournoi à
14h17h
pas besoin d'une licence pour jouer
simplement d'un compte sur cheesecom
et la finale samedi 10 décembre à 20h
avec 100 places limité les places
donnent aussi accès
à l'arène et aux commentaires pendant
les tournois puisqu'on aura un Baki qui
sera assis là sur une de ses chaises
pour le tournoi de 14h on aura aussi
évidemment du Libye du Cornetto du Mazo
du max Lagarde et pas que
ce sera que en présentiel aura un live
non ce sera ah tu pourras suivre le
match aussi en live mais sinon
le tournoi tout le monde jour en
présentiel aura personne qui sera que
chez lui sur internet pour éviter les
plugs qui viendra sans son plug
qui le laissera la maison pour les title
on entend plus on t'entend pas trop à
qui tu dis c'est trop c'est trop ouais
si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'informations et prendre des places qui
sont pris de 20 euros pour la place
spectateur et 25 pour la place joueur
est-ce que le 49e c'est inscrit massage
je peux pas en fait j'ai pas j'ai pas
les trucs en direct j'ai pas les
chiffres en direct
l'autre vie qui peut pas avoir ah non
non c'est pas c'est pas ludique qui gère
ça là il y a beaucoup non là il y a
beaucoup de gens qui non mais c'est un
énorme c'est difficile de s'imaginer à
quel point c'est du boulot en terme de
logistique
et en terme de plaisir en terme de
plaisir
c'est pas pour tout de suite samedi
[Musique]
samedi donc c'est du 1 1 c'est ça va
être du Bullet du 1 + 1
en fait ça c'est pas joueur d'échec
c'est joueur de belette avant tout
genre de belette avant tout
joueur de pelote
mais je crois qu'il clique un peu Yann
aussi qui a le meilleur classement là
pour partir en une année on va voir dès
que ça part on aura les classements qui
seront affichés quoi que je peux les
avoir là ah non j'ai des classements
Blitz ils ont changé le truc ouais sur
l'interface d'avant tu avais tous les
classements mais plus maintenant avec le
nouveau chascom
allez bon deux points d'écart mais
attention ça va vite les deux premiers
belettes vont être
faut pas refaire la même erreur que le
que le cavalier C3 dans la partie
précédente
que les deux c'est quand même des
joueurs de
pas de Tilt mais de série de série ouais
de vagues quand tu commences à bien
jouer que ce soit Maxime ou Yann ça joue
de mieux en mieux une attention de pas
faire la première erreur
faire une erreur du jeu d'échec
pas faire d'erreur de jeux d'échec
bon Maxime sait que gagner c'est plus
important que progresser
ah bah oui c'est
gagner une partie
je t'avais je t'avais dit 3h30 3h45 ça
va finir vers 22h30 2h entre 22h30 et
22h45 mais compte plutôt 22h45 quand
même j'avais pas tort ça va vraiment se
finir à 22h45
faut vraiment que tu es que des joueurs
forts faut pas enfin tu vois genre
Nakamura par avion je te cache pas que
bon
ça peut à certains moments être un peu
long quoi
à partir de la troisième partie c'est ça
ouais ça peut ça peut vite être long
enfin Nakamura contre quasi tout le
monde en fait c'est vite long
ça aurait pu être lancé mais bon ok
c'est de beaux joueurs quand même donc
une demi-heure ça va mais quand je moi
je te parle pas trois points avant les
bolets je te parle de 7 points d'avance
en 5 + 1 en fait
mais je crois que Maxime il avait
commenté avec toi Magnus comparable non
ouais ouais on avait commenté un match
long avec Maxime ensemble
c'est pas encore repas surtout avec ces
nouvelles pauses c'est-à-dire qu'avant
c'était déjà long quand il y avait pas
les pauses en milieu de 7 allez ça part
cette fois-ci on a on a le bon chrono
et on a maximum avec les Noirs donc en
belette c'est quoi 385 3097 donc niveau
équivalent mais Maxime qui a deux points
de plus ça devrait il devrait pouvoir
amener cet avantage jusqu'au bout c'est
quoi cette ouverture
et petit truc petit truc marrant bah qui
avant de parler de la position c'est que
Maxime a gagné les deux 7 5 points à 4
sur le même score bah les deux les deux
sections
il a pas le temps de roquer là les
chances de foot case noir c'est plutôt
bien pour Maxime je trouve
du Grand rock en fait
puisqu'il a les trois puntos là devant
cavalier 5 c'est peut-être bien joué ce
qui a value 5 il a le temps de décider
attention à F4 quand même
oui ça dépend pour qui bon il est pas
bien en fait nepo il joue plus vite en 5
+ 5 en 3 + 1 mais je joue moins vite en
belette que Maxime en fait Maxime il a
compris les cadences
c'est ça la différence entre les deux
coups
j'ai quoi trop cavalué il a réussi à se
remettre
et à repartir vers helsinko
attention à la maxime
de pas se faire ouvrir
ouais ça clique ça clique de partout
voilà c'est compliqué la position est
complexe
mais je le sens bien ce poteau en ces
deux mois
les 20 secondes d'écart aussi
mais bon
il va quand même Adam ouais ça va faire
Punto Yann tissu
[Musique]
ou quelque chose comme ça non mais oui
il peut même pas parce qu'il y avait le
fou en l'air
faut abandonner là monsieur
après s'il veut jouer et faire couler le
temps on est peut-être pas compte en
réalité c'est peut-être bien pour nous
qui la joue celle-là Yann
c'est fini
non il continue quand même Baki
[Musique]
peut se faufiler
encore
un petit espoir
mais bon qui va vite être douchée
bon merci d'avoir laissé tourner la
pendule deux minutes monsieur népomashi
en fait il laisse tourner pour pas
perdre avec des points d'écart
c'est peut-être ça mais ça là elle fait
du bien parce qu'on était pas bien parti
dans la partie précédente et Yann qui
aurait pu recoller un point Maxime qui
le maintient derrière
allez il faut il faut continuer et la
maxime qui joue mieux en belette ses
ouvertures là aussi on sent la kiffer
les cars Maxime ça y est
il y a une qui recommence un peu à
craquer Maxime
ouais
c'est ça y est ça explose ce côté Yann
ça baille il faut aller dormir monsieur
mais bon il est tard en Russie il est
minuit minuit passé après ça doit pas se
coucher tôt côté Yann je pense
c'est pas comme les quatre heures du mat
de chez Dingo
ça passe mais bon
ça baille et ça va pas faire plaisir à
la patronne à mon avis
oui en fait bon tu as perdu tu vas te
coucher à 1h du matin oui bon il y a
rien qui va en fait
j'ai absolument rien qui va
si on faut la finir quand même celle-là
parce que le roi est assez faible
une tour qui rentre et on est on a
touche pas les cases encore
Maxime il faudrait un cavalier qui qui
se faufile en Russie sous quelque part
mais
4 ça c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle la
case F3 il arrive dans le 6
c'est fini pour terminer c'est terminé
bah qui c'est terminé ça va faire un
nouveau Punto pour pour Maxime
va les carrés grand bah ça fait 4 points
ça fait quatre points mais dans les
parties aussi ça fait une grosse diff
ouais
santé depuis une heure et demie deux
heures déjà
qui joue pas du tout il joue plus du
tout en belette en fait c'est-à-dire que
ça fait très longtemps qu'il a pas joué
s'il a un tel coefficient en guerre il
est retombé à 200990
et en fait il a pas du tout préparé
cette partie du match Yann
et là Maxime qui a qui fait un bon match
qui se
préparé que la berlinoise
ouais j'ai pas trop compris l'approche
dans le match de Yann après
mais attention là il fait une grande
partie
il joue un peu Parakou mais je vois pas
comment dans ces conditions là il peut
en gagner 4 d'affilée personnellement il
y a trop de gaffe
il y a trop de gaffe à qui
qui lui a l'air très affûté faut dire
aussi qu'il y a le championnat du monde
de Bleach fin décembre Maxime qui doit
avoir à cœur de défendre son titre voire
même d'aller chercher celui en rapide
si même là il laisse il laisse les dames
3 il laisse énormément de chance les
cases blanches
ça va encore faire Punto
ça va encore faire Punto backi et tout
réduite
ado ça va faire plus 5 tu avais raison
de dire que ce match pouvait être long
maintenant le 23 dernières minutes
ouais c'est bien joué en réalité
c'était probablement sale chance oui en
réalité c'est même très bien joué de la
part de Yann
mais bon c'est trop ce qu'il a fait
les deux joueurs ont vraiment joué sur
leur point fort respectifs et leurs
points faibles
et on menace à 7 à 8 faut trouver faut
trouver l'idée là pour mater c'est pas
si facile
il revient juste défendre
ouais mais faut la gagner si tu m'as pas
à tourner vite
qui est pas forcément mécontent d'avoir
échangé
il va envoyer le pion des bons il va
faire mieux avec les 6
attention à qui il va menacer
5 D6 d'un Français 4 D7
attention on a peut-être chanté un peu
vite Baki enfin surtout moi trois points
il revient Yann mais bon c'est ça
mais bon ça là elle aurait jamais dû
être perdue
concentré ça va pas ça va pas durer
parce que dans le jeu il est nettement
au-dessus là dans les belettes
il est nettement plus fort et ça envoie
de la ruse et ça fait pas le petit rock
attention là
erreur d'arbitrage côté chaise comme ça
laisse des ruisses passer
mais en revanche dans ces positions là
Maxime il a pas dans ses ouvertures là
il a jamais vraiment réussi à
prendre l'avantage
il veut quoi il veut foi E5 il faut
peut-être prendre en G7 quand même
peut-être pour te protéger au 5 donc
elle va les H2 cavalier prend 5 qui fait
quoi pour 1 ou F4 non F4
il a perdu un punto
il aura souffert dans ses ouvertures là
il y aura souffert contre les ruises
Maxime où il a raté X à 4
[Musique]
Maxime qui défend un peu viens jouer là
de ramener la tour en H1
tu as raison Maxime qui a réussi encore
une fois à défendre l'indéfendable
il devrait pas avoir toutes ses chances
mais
il a il se les ai faites aussi un Maxime
mais c'est la grosse différence dans
leur c'est la différence dans le match
ouais
c'est qu'en fait
gagner quand même assez facilement ça va
peut-être repartir sur une nul
ça va repartir
[Musique]
c'est trop
pour Yann
pour des deux tours tout simplement
et ça c'est terminé
ouais non il y a trop de trop d'écart
trop d'écart dans le niveau
c'est tranquille genre deux points ça
revenait un peu mais quatre points il y
a pas de risque encore on a vu dès les
deux premiers bulles à toi que c'était
que c'était fini moi il y a une
domination dans tous les tous les
compartiments
18 minutes de jeu Maxime qui doit avoir
besoin de il reste peut-être six parties
il a besoin d'un point et demi sur 6 et
encore c'est
c'est peut-être même pas tant que ça
Maxime au dessus de mes pots
qui va se retrouver en quart de finale
on verra un contre contre peut-être
contre Wesley un joueur qui lui réussit
un peu comme il y a un encore un joueur
qui lui réussit plutôt bien il a un
tableau de joueurs très fort avec les
joueurs qui lui réussissent
avec
un peu compliqué
[Musique]
pas facile à jouer dans dans les dans
les bullets
qui l'attaque vous procède dame G3 et H5
là qui arrive
c'est dur
attention
quand même
après Wesley il sera plus sur ces format
là il est plus fort que Yann ça c'est
sûr c'est évident il a fait finaliste
deux ou trois années de suite
et à chaque fois il perd contre Naka
mais après il était toujours dans les
bons dans les bonnes parties de tableaux
quand il a fait final mais il est
le truc c'est qu'il est solide ouais il
donnera pas de points comme ça en fait
il en donne pas beaucoup
il va plus se préparer pour le pour le
tournoi
mais c'est sûr que sur sur le tournoi
sur sur ce tournoi là
il va y avoir un petit problème là soit
sur C5 soit sur
H5 déjà le petit problème sur C5 aussi
ça va être une pièce ça
joli quand même de jouer au 5 et
cavaliers de direct
il fait même pas fou français 5 dames
prendre des 7 il en veut encore plus
[Musique]
moyen d'enjeu plus il perd ouais c'est
un peu de ça
[Musique]
mais bon
dur de garder la même intensité
[Musique]
elle est bizarre celle-là
mais bon
ça a toujours été le défaut du format
c'est pour ça que je préfère les formes
à 7 déjà tu as plus de monter en
puissance
des moments importants qui clochent et
que tu peux facilement repérer et en
plus ça évite
en fait
et là c'est lui qui repart sur les
échecs et qui fait nul moi j'essaie
à prendre nul 5 points d'avance
14 minutes je pense qu'il manque un demi
point à Maxime
pour se débarrasser de Yann
mais c'est marrant ça s'est joué ouais
ça s'est joué à l'heure de jeu là après
après tu as 30 40 minutes de jeu là il y
a un moment où Maxime a pris un peu le
dessus et ça a jamais le match à peu
plus changer de dynamique après
c'est resté sur cette dynamique a
peut-être une déco ouais ah oui ça joue
peut-être pour déco encore ou misclick
mais là il va en falloir beaucoup des
mystiques
c'est plutôt déco
fin de l'abondance aide
parce que là toutes les parties en plus
elles sont ouais là maintenant
ça y est c'est ça fait penser de ce
match de rugby toi je sais que tu suis
moins mais des fois quand tu as une
équipe qui a pris le dessus l'autre
équipe elle explose dans toutes les
mêlés enfin elle explose partout sur le
match est très serré et tout d'un coup
en fait je reçois 65e minute tu sens il
y a une équipe qui qui fait la diff et à
partir de ce moment là bon bah c'est il
y a plus une phase de contact qui est en
faveur de l'équipe dominée en fait
ça fait un peu penser à ça
sert à rien
ça clique quoi
maintenant
[Musique]
c'est complètement explosé torgessinko
merci au revoir
ça joue bien ça clique bien comme un
côté Maxime ça y est cette fois-ci c'est
fini c'est ma thématiquement fini backy
il ne peut plus rien arriver à Maxime
qui se qualifie
c'est officiel déjà je le dis avant de
chasse comme Maxime qualifié pour les
quarts de finale où il retrouvera
peut-être du Wesley peut-être
de la torov deux joueurs que nous avons
battu avec Baki c'est pour dire ça doit
pas être très fort en face non ça ça
pourrait ça sera dangereux en les deux
pareil Abdou qui peut
à mon avis sur un speed chasse être
beaucoup plus dangereux que sur un title
même chose pour Wesley qui sera plus
dangereux que sur les titles aussi
donc ce sera un match encore une fois un
55 ans et une victoire de Maxime nous
offrirait Baki une demi-finale de rêve
une Carouge magmouche
[Musique]
hyper fort mais de joueurs contre qui
perfe bien
mais après peut-être une finale contre
Dingo pourquoi pas
de l'autre côté on a qui ikaro il a
gagné déjà qu'on par avion
alors il a pas encore joué mais il a
déjà gagné en fait
[Rires]
il a déjà gagné
il a déjà gagné 100 jouets et
après après je sais plus le tableau
je l'ai quelque part
Maxime marlou qui qui
abandonne tout de suite pour jouer un
maximum de pellets contre Yann pour
prendre les 30 octobre
Maxime en plus Carlsen il joue Goku cash
au premier tour
je pense que ça va aller et il joue
Caruana au deuxième
mais il vaut mieux que
il est dangereux oui bien sûr mais bon
et Ding il va jouer contre le vainqueur
de NiAl Guiri
et après et Naka il joue par avion après
le vainqueur d'aronia André Kin donc en
fait
n'a qu'à dingly Rennes c'est déjà sur
et en fait le seul truc qui est pas sûr
c'est oui soit d'où ça tu auras c'est
pas sûr mais après Maxime Abdou c'est
pas sûr en fait c'est quasiment tu as
quasiment trois gars déjà en demi Naka
Ding et Carlson et la question c'est
dans le carré de Maxime ou les quatre
joueurs pouvaient se qualifier en fait
c'est le carré le plus serré
je pense les gros favoris au prochain
match maximum
je pense aussi mais enfin je veux dire
que Naka contre aronia ou André King on
s'est peut-être même pas la peine de
jouer le match non plus et digne ok
enfin dinguerie
le match
c'est mieux de le jouer quand même mais
ça peut être long
oui ou non
regarde le match mais
c'est hyper long mais là c'est un match
quand même plutôt serré et c'est plutôt
cool ce que c'est Maxime qui gagne mais
oui c'est long
les dix dernières minutes et c'est on
est sur un match je te jure que j'ai vu
des matchs ou c'était deux heures et
demie comme ça
bonne chance commentateur
mais
pas toi non c'est pas moi Carlson
parce que c'est juste
le problème c'est que plus personne n'a
envie quoi les joueurs ont plus envie
non plus ça se voit dans les cours en
fait bah oui c'est que
c'est pas comme le match nakafiruja
qu'on a regardé l'autre fois qui est
amical où ils ont joué pour les ponts
hello jusqu'au bout et toutes les
parties étaient intéressantes tout le
long
là il clique parce qu'il va se cliquer
alors
6 points d'écart 8 minutes à jouer oui
ah les joueurs peuvent abandonner dans
les 10 derniers c'est une nouveauté
cette année belle nouveauté robinside
mais nepo est peut-être pas au courant
parce que je pense que si il savait il
aurait abandonné très franchement
Maxime il peut abandonner aussi non il a
le droit aussi j'imagine ah mais ce
qu'il a le droit de dire ok c'est 2
minutes par partie je donne 5 Punto mais
je me barre quoi
mais oui il a dû oublier qu'il avait le
droit d'abandonner tellement l'habitude
des anciennes règles
ultime en fait ce serait que Maxime
abandonne là merci au revoir messieurs
quoi
il va pas le faire mais si on a un de
monde qui était capable de faire ça ce
serait Maxime en fait juste pour le
troll ultime les gars abandonnent
[Musique]
c'est quand même dommage qui est pas de
pause après 15 minutes de belette pas
qui
on aurait pu prévenir Yann il pouvait
abandonner en fait
si Maxime joue comme ça il peut
retourner en finale
si refait des matchs comme ça
ça peut aller très loin
ça peut aller très très loin
mais ça se voit que c'est bien préparé
Maxime pour le match
ça se voit qu'il était très préparé pour
le match
et le quart de finale je pense que ce
sera entre le 12 et le 15 décembre
je crois ce sera après
un regardable
en fait il y a plus d'intensité dans les
couilles je tempo ils ont tous envie ça
se finisse et n'est pas dû oublier que
ah j'ai 8 pas de chance
du rock tout 2016 c'est quand je vais
rejouer
il n'y a pas de tournoi
février ça reprend février peut-être
j'aurais tendance en janvier je sais pas
c'est trop ce match
après
c'est que la fin fin
c'était hyper intéressant jusqu'à un
moment mais là c'est trop
bah c'est pire que rien en fait tu
préfères voir rien en fait
non mais
tu as pas envie de voir des mauvaises
parties comme ça
surtout que c'était quand même bien
jusqu'à un moment et du coup bah c'est
ça ça donne en fait le match est très
bien et ça te donne une mauvaise
impression sans raison en fait
juste ça s'est arrêté tu subis pas ce
truc là enfin tout le monde le subit là
les joueurs les gens enfin tout le monde
encore dans des matchs qui sont pas où
le résultat il est couru d'avance que
des fois tu as les joueurs qui
qui essaient quand même de bien jouer
il attend la fin
mais comme tu as ça à la fin qui dure
une demi-heure tu ça te laisse quand
même une dernière mauvaise impression
alors que ça devrait pas être le calme
c'était superbe
mais là c'est vrai que tu as deux
joueurs qui veulent plus jouer Maxime
professionnel il finit le match mais
n'est pas il est au bout pourquoi il a
donné sa dame parce qu'en fait il a pris
une tour d'abord sur échec et après s'il
donne pas sa dame sur le tour il y avait
un matin donc il a été obligé de le
sacrifier à ce moment là mais ça va
tellement vite en plus soit les belettes
quand il y a pas de quand il y a pas
d'intérêt sportif c'est horrible
alors que là
c'est du clic
il doit pas il doit pas savoir il doit
pas avoir la ref
ait c'est 5 jolies coups
maintenant il y a des menaces de maths
sur le sur le roi mais bon
il peut s'en sortir d'un mec 2 d'un
médecin
mais ça va être la dernière
alors est-ce que Maxime va rester au
dessus des 3100 ou est-ce que nepo va
repasser les 3000
à la question je pense qu'il s'en
foutent complètement bah qui
seul intérêt que je vois en fait à cette
partie là avec 54 bien joué oh là là
ça rentre et toi tu es à combien du coup
en belette oh pas beaucoup pas beaucoup
je clique de temps en temps mais je te
vois souvent quand même cliquer je suis
très mauvaise
demain tu vas être favori du title
ment avant le title
jouait tu vas voir le cerveau en
ébullition
on verra
mais c'est la semaine dernière j'ai
battu abdos
c'était il y a deux semaines ou tu as
battu tout le monde tu étais survolté
à 4 sur 7 à un moment donné je me
rappelle ça
c'est de me prendre des 5 draps aussi
il fallait éviter le dame j'ai cette
natte du coup c'est encore la pause ce
qui nous rejoigne
j'ai arrêté le chrono pour pas qu'on se
fasse bipède
tu l'as pas entendu mais là le chrono
est terminé
n'oubliez pas la backup le 10
décembre prendre les places spectateurs
Ludwig qui va remettre un lien une
dernière fois
important
il reste encore des places spectateurs
il en reste plus beaucoup de place
joueur dans ta pool il reste encore des
places c'est les dernières là
alors que vous pouvez gagner le drapeau
utilisez le soir même ta poule pour un
tournoi d'anthologie
spectateur il reste encore quand même
des places
il reste plus que 20 places tu me diras
donc ça part quand même vite et dans ta
poule je vais te dire
ta poule dernière article topo en fait
quand c'est les derniers sinon je peux
voir mais moi même je peux plus voir en
fait mais c'est sûr
moins de 10 places dans ta poule et je
sens ici quoi vas-y il dit qu'il a déjà
le drapeau en fait il est pas obligé de
il est pas obligé de jouer le tournoi
mais bon
ce que je te propose pendant que vous
achetez vos places tranquillement nous
on va redescom comme ça vous allez avoir
l'interview de Maxime et on vous dit à
demain pour le title merci à tous à
bientôt merci ciao ciao ciao puis bravo
Maxime pour le match de coupe bien
entendu
capitaine du coup ah bah oui tu peux
gagner sans ses lunettes ou c'est sa
casquette du coup